Pop pop, ba-da, pop-ba-bra, pop-bop.
Welcome home, master, princess.
Hello everybody!
Hello!
Welcome back to Metal Gear Saturdays!
Yippee!
Hello, hello, hello, Minto.
Hello, hello.
Hey, big boss.
No.
Just boss.
Good morning, Minto!
I just came back from an all-night idol live.
Go to sleep?
What are you doing?
The music is so creepy.
I love being called Ojousama by Minto.
You are my Ojousama!
Or Goshijinsama.
Could be both.
I don't know.
Pick one.
Thanks for the five gifted!
Thank you!
Yeah!
So...
More Metal Gear.
I don't know.
I'm kind of blocking it, but it says like...
On the bottom right, it says like W.S.
As if I'm not playing on a controller.
Day two ago, I bought the collection and played through MGS1, but couldn't beat the final.
Too much trolling.
What do you mean too much trolling?
You couldn't beat Rex?
I believe in you.
If I can do it, you can do it.
Unless you mean...
No.
What?
Probably the chase.
I was going to say, unless you mean the chase segment.
No.
Well today...
So I was... initially it was just like...
I'm going to play super duper long.
If I beat the game, cool.
If I don't, we'll save it for another day.
But I wanted to get close.
But now I'm thinking...
I was thinking, I was like, oh man.
I have a concert next week.
I should probably...
Not be doing super duper duper long streams.
Just so I can protect my voice a little bit.
Happy Canada Day.
Oh Canada.
So...
Not to say that I won't go long.
But I'm thinking...
I don't know.
We'll go.
We'll just...
We'll just go.
And when I feel like it's an appropriate time...
I'm thinking maybe...
Like before Vulcan Raven.
Because...
Then once I get to Vulcan Raven, I think...
That's like a decent point...
After him...
To be able to beat the game.
Maybe.
I don't know.
Maybe going things into Five Gifted!
Thank you.
So we'll see.
We'll see how far I get.
How well I do on some of these...
On some of these bosses.
And...
Yeah.
So...
Uh...
Yeah.
We'll just see.
I'll just...
I'll just play.
And have a good time.
And hopefully you guys...
Have a good time too!
Talkers!
Oh!
Thanks for the Five Gifted!
Thank you!
Thank you guys.
You did really well last time.
I hope so.
I want to go through the entire Metal Gear series.
Which games do I play after the first three?
Four!
One, two, three...
Four...
Peace Walker...
Ground Zeroes...
Five.
If you're starting from there.
Yeah!
Pyro bug!
Thanks for that time!
Thank you!
So...
Um...
Let's see.
Uh...
For those who aren't sure.
We stopped right before Psycho Mantis.
Um...
So we will be starting the stream with Psycho Mantis.
And I am playing on Integral.
Well done!
Thanks for the five!
Ready for her to scream.
Stop it.
No.
I have to protect my voice.
Hahaha.
I have to protect my voice for...
Concert next week!
Psycho Mantis.
Yeah.
Hahaha.
I'm playing on...
Integral?
Uh...
But it's in English.
Don't worry.
Oh.
Maybe I should make myself a little smaller.
Like that?
There we go.
Hahaha.
My sleeve is a little large.
And in charge.
Oh.
Oh my gosh.
Thank you guys for all the...
Super chats!
I remember this coming out and using my chore money to buy it.
Hahaha.
Oh my gosh.
I remember having to use my chore money to buy games too.
Before I forget, I was surprised to see Ayame Sensei's panel at ASEN.
Yeah!
Hehe.
Hope the spicy snacks didn't cook your gut.
Hahaha.
Do you think Ayame would be interested in playing the Metal Gear series?
No.
Ayame Sensei is not really...
She doesn't really play games.
If I tell her...
If I tell her to play something, she's like...
I don't really play video games.
You know what?
That's okay.
Dog Strings!
Thanks to the five gifters!
Maple, welcome back!
We can watch this just to...
Archipelago.
How would a Balenciaga mint Metal Gear first?
Balenciaga!
I don't even know what Balenciaga looks like.
They're demanding that the government turn over the remains of Big Boss.
And they say that if their demands are not met with their demands, they will not be able to do so.
That's what I'm saying.
They will not be able to do so.
I know, right?
And what they are saying is that if you don't do so, they will not be able to do so.
And I will change the subtitles.
They will be in English.
So don't you worry.
Foxhound.
DARPA.
Kenneth...
Kenneth Baker.
Terrorist.
Kenny!
Bye!
What's the insertion method?
We'll approach the disposal facility by sub.
How's the audio?
We'll launch a one-man SDV.
Kenneth Baca.
After the SDV gets as close as it can, dispose it.
You smell like a Baca.
Thereon, you'll have to swim.
Kenneth Baker.
Is that it?
Okay.
I'm inserting.
I take special forces unit Foxhound.
Foxhound.
Your former unit.
And one that I was a commander of.
Oh, I also want to say...
So they're still around.
Here, I'll type it.
There are six members of Foxhound involved in this terrorist activity.
Psycho Mattis, with his powerful psychic abilities.
Sniper Wolf, a beautiful and deadly sharpshooter.
No spoilers.
Decoy Octopus.
Not for me, but for anyone who may have not played the series before.
Thanks.
Thank you.
And Revolver Ocelot.
I love that guy.
And a formidable gunfighter.
And finally, in charge of them, Foxhound's squad leader.
Giant and Shamer.
Do you play the OG games on stream?
Yeah, probably.
I've played them before.
The nuclear weapons disposal facility covers the whole island.
I'll instruct you by codec after you reach your target.
Anyone going with me?
Nope.
This is a one-man infiltration mission.
Sneaking mission.
Yes.
This is a top-secret black op.
Don't expect any official support.
Aw, man.
I need support.
At least I have Master Miller.
NES version?
Sure.
Yay!
Metal Gear Solid Integra!
Oh my god, I'm muscle-matching!
Thank you so much for the 50 gifted.
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you!
So, let me make sure the subtitles and stuff are in English.
Caption on.
Vibration on, baby.
On, baby.
Okay.
That should be good.
Wait.
Did it save?
Hold on, sorry.
Okay, good, good, good, good.
Okay, okay, okay.
Alright, so...
We're right before...
Right before...
Psychobiontis.
The nuclear building basement 1.
What is this one?
Oh, did I only do two saves?
Okay.
Read mission log?
No, I think we're good.
But I do like seeing the art.
I can't believe Mint isn't playing in the optimal order of four survive, one rising, three, five, and then peaceful.
I know, right?
Blasphemy.
Okay, let's go.
Okay.
I know this place better than you.
I'll be point man.
Follow me.
Okay, good.
So, that left us off right here.
We got to do the whole cutscene.
Okay.
With Meryl.
That's me.
In the mirror.
Man in the mirror.
I don't know how that song goes.
Just go look at her pants one more time.
Oh, yeah, baby.
Well, they probably smell like soldier, huh?
That's strange.
There's no guard.
And no music.
What happened to the music?
I'll keep a lookout.
Make sure you're ready, okay?
Okay.
Why do you have to say it like that, Meryl?
Why do you have to say it like that, huh?
What?
What is it?
What if I get really close to her?
Oh.
Wow.
Every pixel is visible.
What are you staring at?
She's getting red.
Get red.
Come on, Snake.
Get a snake.
Get as red as your hair.
Wow, them pixels.
Don't stare at me like that.
Am I making you embarrassed?
What are you doing?
I'm being...
We've got to get a move on.
I'm being so silly.
Look at all those pixels.
Yeah.
What?
What is it?
Get red.
Become a tomato.
What is it?
What are you staring at?
I'm just, you know, your tomato body.
All right.
Let's see now.
I know that there's...
I can't go in there.
But I can grab the diazepam and the night vision goggles.
And, um...
And, uh...
Man, I sure love them torpedoes.
So calm.
This is a ration.
I'm full on ration.
Oh, nice.
Okay.
Beep.
Let's get all these things.
All these goodies.
Stun grenade.
No.
We're good.
That one...
Oh, I can go in here.
Cardboard box B!
Nice.
Okay, guys.
We're going to go in there.
Oh!
Yes?
What?
Wait, why is she running here?
Hello?
Why did you come in here?
What?
Look how red she is still.
She heard you scream.
Okay, let's go fight...
a guy.
Oh gosh.
Beryl, I have to pee first.
Okay.
You ready?
I like the way she like...
Wait, did you turn un-red?
No, I think it's just the lighting.
Okay.
I'm nervous!
Psycho Mantis was really hard for me before.
So I'm nervous.
Oh gosh.
Here we go.
I don't remember his patterning...
like his patterns at all.
Oh, I don't have...
Wait, I don't have full health.
Maybe I should go get the rations.
Snake, what are you doing?
Let's go to the commander's room.
But Meryl...
My health!
Meryl, please.
Understand.
Meryl.
Oh no, I'm not at full health.
It's okay.
I could always reload.
Here we go.
Ouch!
It hurts.
What's wrong?
Don't come here, Snake.
I love this part.
Are you okay?
What happened?
Snake is not doing any...
You good?
I'm fine.
Okay.
Let's go.
I love this part.
Say the line.
Come on, Mr. Foxhound.
The commander is waiting.
Yeah!
I love that line so much.
It's so cool.
Come on, Mr. Foxhound.
The commander is waiting.
Oh, boy.
Oh, golly.
Don't you...
Snake...
How do you like me?
What the...
Do you like me?
Hold me, Snake.
What's wrong?
Oh, hurry, hurry.
Don't fight!
Psycho Mantis, you freak!
You don't like girls!
Why am I okay then?
Okay.
I'll knock her out.
Come on, Meryl.
Get it together.
Get it together, Meryl.
Meryl.
Meryl, get it together.
Meryl!
I mean, this man is floating, Snake!
What are you talking about?
You doubt my power.
This guy is floating in thin air!
Now, I will show you why I am the most powerful practitioner of psychokinesis and telepathy in the world.
In the world.
No, there's no need for words, Snake.
Yeah.
I am Psycho Mantis!
Yippee!
That's right.
This is no trick.
It's true power.
I can hear the mechanics of, like, the...
It's useless.
I told you.
...wiring holding him up in the ceiling.
Now, let me read your mind.
Oh, my God.
Now, perhaps I should say your past.
You are a very methodical man.
Mm-hmm.
The type that always kicks his tires before he leaves.
You are a highly skilled warrior, well-suited to this...
Stop!
Are you kidding me?
You are a highly skilled warrior, well-suited to this...
I'm a highly skilled warrior!
Oh, I'm a coward?
That's okay, too.
Now, don't believe me.
Oh, my God!
Now, I'll read more deeply into your soul.
I'm a gamer.
Ah, I can see into your mind.
What games do I like?
So, you like Suikoden.
You like Castlevania, don't you?
I like Castlevania.
You enjoy role-playing games.
Role-playing games.
So, you like adventure games.
Ooh, yeah.
I see that you enjoy Konami games.
You have not saved often.
I haven't.
You are somewhat reckless.
I can read you like an open book.
You still don't believe me?
I will show you...
You thought I was safe scumming a little bit.
Put your controller on the floor.
Okay, I put it on my desk.
Put it down as flat as you can.
Yep, hold on.
That's good.
Oh, here.
I'll put it here.
Now, I will move your controller...
I'll put it on my desk.
Hopefully, you guys can hear it.
...at the power of my will alone.
Here it goes.
My
power now.
Oh, my God!
It's moving!
A demonstration.
It's over.
Oh, okay.
Time to get serious.
Oh, gosh!
Oh, God!
No!
Alright.
Master Miller.
Help me.
It's true.
Your enemy is a powerful telepath.
But you've got more battle experience.
I do?
You can do it, Snake.
Oh, my gosh.
He's so nice.
I love Master Miller.
That's Psycho Mantis.
Former KDB psychic.
He has powerful telepathic abilities.
After the collapse of the Soviet Union, he came to America looking for a job.
He worked with the FBI on several cases as a psychic profiler.
Five years ago, he was working on the case of a multiple serial murderer.
He got too far into the killer's mind.
As a result, he became just like the killer.
So he was sort of infected by the serial murderer's thoughts?
In any case, after that, he became a sort of psychic spy.
Psychic spy.
He traveled all around the world.
I love how this is all kind of retconned.
He can read people's minds.
He knows every move that you're going to make.
What should I do?
I've got no chance of beating him.
There must be some way.
He's a master at controlling people, Snake.
Don't let him manipulate you.
No Streamlabs notice?
They're probably blocked or backed up behind a bunch of gifters.
I see your donation, Paul.
Thank you!
Colonel, in which slot does the credit card go?
Thank you so much!
The order you're playing seems fine.
Wait, what are you waiting for?
Okay, here we go.
I don't feel like I need to save.
Justasha, what do you have to say?
It's like a consultant.
Yes.
Although they will not admit it, many countries have paranormal programs.
I can't hear you over the music.
Justasha...
Psychics and their specialists...
Speak up!
Psychics range in power from those who gain bean spoons...
to those who gain commercial disasters.
...to those who gain commercial disasters.
But Psycho Mantis is one of the most powerful.
Be careful.
Meryl is on the ground.
Deep Thrill.
We know he was not going to respond.
Okay.
Dun dun dun dun dun.
Dun dun dun dun dun dun.
Okay, hold on.
Guys, I'm so sorry.
But also, we're just gonna...
controller connection connect as P2.
P has come to.
And...
Yes.
I'm blind.
I know, me too.
Here we go.
Oh, gosh, I can't see.
Oh, God.
This is worse than anything.
This is so bad.
Oh, my gosh.
It's so hard to see.
Dun dun dun dun dun.
And
rain.
Oh, this is...
Okay.
Crouch.
I can't...
Oh, God.
I can't do this, you guys.
I can't do this.
Oh, my God.
It's so impossible to see.
Okay.
Oh, that was close.
What?
What just hit me?
Are you kidding me right now?
What?
Oh, my gosh.
Wait.
Okay.
So, laying down...
What?
Wait a second.
Oh, my gosh, you guys.
I don't...
Uh-oh.
This is bad.
Eek.
It's not even...
It
still hits me even when I'm laying down.
Okay.
That's good to know.
Oh, my God.
The chairs are poisonous!
What?!
Okay.
Oh, my gosh.
Where are you?
Get him!
Oh!
Okay, you guys.
This is not good.
Dude.
But I level...
I thought that the chairs couldn't get me if I lay down.
Clearly, I'm the only one who knows this.
Clearly that's not the case.
The poisonous chairs...
Can I still shoot him from here?
Oh, I can grab that ration.
Ouch!
Oh, grab that ration now?
I can't reach you.
Oh, that was close.
Get him!
Get his butt!
I can hear him.
Oh my god.
Nice.
I got him.
Okay, nice, nice.
I can't remember his patterns at all.
Okay, now he throws the ball, right?
Oh, I ran right into it.
Don't laugh at me.
Don't laugh at me, Psycho Mantis, please.
I'm embarrassed.
Get him!
Get his butt!
Get his butt in front of you!
Okay, now I hide over here.
I can get him from here though, right?
Maybe I can't.
Nice.
Okay.
These guys.
These guys are the bane of my existence!
Wow!
Run away!
Get his butt!
Oh my god.
Oh my goodness.
Ouch!
Get him!
I think he was over here.
He disappeared.
And he's gonna throw a thing at me.
Oh, I'm out!
Oh my god, I'm out of bullets.
I'm out of bullets.
Why no famas?
I don't know.
He's gonna throw a thing.
Okay, chairs.
I can't reach.
Can I still get him?
I'm just shooting into them.
Shooting into them.
Ouch!
You dang statue!
Get his ass!
Whoa!
Ouch!
Ouch
Stop it, Meryl!
You're not yourself when you're hungry!
Oh god!
Come
on!
That was so cheap!
I don't know about this!
Oh shit.
I'm literally running right into them.
Why
are you shooting so slowly, Snake?
I gotta get him.
Please!
Snake, run!
Why isn't it shooting fast?
Oh,
that was close.
Ay ay ay ay!
Oh no!
You guys, this might be the first one that I have to redo.
This might be the first one I have to redo.
Turn around.
No!
The chairs!
Where is he?
I'm just gonna shoot.
I'm gonna shoot.
I'll get you somehow!
Mantis!
Oh my god.
I hate those little guys.
I hate them so much.
Oh my god!
Oh
my god!
Please!
Shut up!
Colonel, your niece is going to be okay.
Thanks, Snake.
I owe you one.
Now that Mantis is beaten, Meryl's brainwashing should wear off.
Right, Naomi?
When it's being a dream, for real.
Why did you go so far out of your way to save her?
For Campbell's sake?
Or maybe it's because you like her?
I don't want to see any woman die right in front of me.
Oh, really?
Since when did anybody's death bother you so much?
Shut up, Naomi.
You're so dramatic.
It's true that Snake has killed a lot of people.
Real psycho Mantis.
That doesn't mean he doesn't have a heart.
It's okay, Colonel.
First try easy.
I know!
She's right.
Actually!
Oh my gosh, you guys.
Maybe I have improved as a gamer.
First try.
A strong man doesn't need to read the future.
He makes his own.
Perhaps so.
But I will read your future.
Showing her skills as a soldier.
As a gamer.
That's why he said I was a skilled soldier.
To Metal Gear's underground maintenance base.
You have to go through that hidden door.
The hidden door behind the bookcase.
The overland route.
It's blocked by frozen glaciers.
Go past the communication towers.
And use the tower's walkway.
You know what fight I always forget about in this game is the hindee.
Why are you telling me this?
I always forget about it.
I can read people's minds.
In my lifetime, I have read the past, present, and futures of thousands upon thousands of men and women.
Ugh, gross.
Oh, gross.
And each mind that I peered into was stuffed with the same single object of obsession.
That selfish and atavistic desire to pass on one seed.
It was enough to make me sick.
Every living thing on this planet exists to mindlessly pass on their DNA.
We're designed that way.
And that's why there is war.
But you...
You are different.
I'm not like other soldiers.
You're the same as us.
We have no past, no future.
We live in the moment.
That's our only purpose.
Humans weren't designed to bring each other happiness.
From the moment we're thrown into this world...
we're fated to bring each other nothing but pain and misery.
You're wrong.
The first person whose mind I dove into...
was my father's.
I saw nothing but disgust and hatred for me in his heart.
My mother died in childbirth.
And he despised me for it.
I thought my father...
was going to kill me.
That's when my future...
disappeared.
I lost my past as well.
Everything on fire, baby!
The village was engulfed in flames.
Fire!
Are you saying that you burned your village down to bury your past?
I see that you have suffered the same trauma.
Ewww.
Sounds like me when I hear the girl's laugh.
We are truly the same.
You and I.
The world is a more interesting place with people like you and...
We're not like you, Psycho Mantis.
I never agreed with the boss's revolution.
His dreams of world conquest do not interest me.
I just wanted an excuse to kill as many people as I could.
You're a weirdo.
You monster.
Let him talk.
He doesn't have much time left.
I've seen through evil.
You, Snake.
You're just like the boss.
Let him cook.
Now you're worse...
compared to you.
I'm not so bad.
This guy sucks so much.
Poor Snake.
He doesn't deserve this.
I let Caroline as well.
Meryl's...
You match my freak.
I saw you there.
You have a large place in your heart.
A large place?
Yes.
A large place.
But I do not know if your futures lie together.
I have a last chance.
I have a last request.
What is it?
My mask.
Put it back on.
Okay.
Like this, other people's thoughts force their way into my mind.
Before I die, I want to be by myself.
I want to be left alone in my own world.
He's like, reach for it.
He's like, lift your head, buddy.
Reach for it.
I know you're dying.
I want to find your future.
Go through that door.
This is the first time I've ever used my power to help someone.
It's strange.
It feels...
Kind of...
Nice.
No.
No life, no bullets.
You knocked the heck out of Meryl.
Let's go, Meryl.
Thank you.
Bye.
I'm sorry.
Meryl?
How could I let Mantis control my mind like that?
I know.
How embarrassing.
If you're gonna doubt yourself, I'll leave you here.
You're right.
Never doubt yourself.
Just let it make you stronger.
Learn something from it.
You're right.
I'm sorry.
I won't do it again.
The mirror being smashed.
It's so sad.
Snake, can I ask you something?
What?
About what Mantis said.
I was just wondering.
What?
What's the problem now?
I think what...
Oh.
I think the way Snake acts here...
So, tell me, Snake.
What's your name?
I think what Mantis said really got to him, you know?
Your real name.
A name means nothing on the battlefield.
He's just like, yeah, I am just a...
Old enough to know what death looks like.
...weapon.
Any family?
No.
He's a bit shook.
But I was raised by many people.
Yeah.
Is there anyone you like?
I've never been interested in anyone you like.
I've never been interested in anyone else's life.
So you are all alone.
Just like Mantis said.
Say it.
Other people just complicate my life.
Say what you're thinking, Meryl.
I don't like to get involved.
Be honest.
You're a sad, lonely man.
Dang.
Not that honest.
Let's go.
Yay.
Defeat Psycho Mantis.
Oh.
It's saying to put it... change it back to controller one.
Okay.
Thank you, game.
Wait.
Yes.
It's P1.
There we go.
Okay.
So I've basically exhausted all of my materials here.
Can I...
Oh, Psycho Mantis.
Oh.
Kiss.
Wait.
How do I get that angle again?
Wow.
Oh.
Yes.
I know she's a pro gamer.
Thank you.
Can I go back now?
Oh.
That's not the door.
What are you doing?
We've got to get a move on.
Meryl.
There was rations back there.
You don't understand.
I have...
Oh.
I have 29 bullets.
I have 12 bullets.
This is bad.
It's fine, though.
We're fine.
Probably.
I know there's a ration in here.
Isn't there?
Or there's stuff.
Yeah.
Okay.
We got a little bit at least.
Here we go.
And then more bullets.
Oh.
Could there be wolves in there?
Wolf dogs.
Half wolf.
Half husky.
How do you know so much?
I almost said dog wolves.
I'm a musher.
I love...
I'll take point.
Snake, you follow me.
Okay.
Don't leave me behind, though.
Meryl.
That would be really rude of you.
Okay.
Girlie.
Don't...
Don't leave me behind.
I believe you went this way.
It would be really, really, really rude of you.
Nice.
Oh.
You bitch.
There's more stuff down there, too.
I never realized.
Thank you.
I'll take all that I can get right now.
Oh.
Hmm.
I don't want to kill the dogs, but...
I could stun the dogs.
But I only have three.
We shouldn't waste them.
I don't want to kill the dogs.
What's that sound?
The pups?
The dogs walking around?
See?
Look.
It's a dog.
That's a full...
That's a wolf dog.
That's a full wolf dog.
They won't...
Will they bother me if I'm in the box?
I can't remember.
Awww.
Little pup.
Mushing makes me feel good.
I can't remember if they bother me in the box.
I do.
It's so hard to see in here.
I'm just afraid I'm going to get lost.
I got to get peed on first.
Oh no.
Okay.
Inconvenienced.
What do you mean inconvenienced?
It's more like death.
What are you talking about?
Oh, actually, let's call people.
Let's see what Campbell says.
Yeah.
Be careful.
Wolves have the advantage in the dark.
Not only can they see better, but they have a keen sense of smell as well.
You'd better use your night vision goggles.
Oh.
Okay.
Because...
I'll only use it because Campbell told me to.
You know, the Colonel.
Don't suddenly look into the dark.
Look slowly from a light area to a darker area.
If you do that, your eyes will gradually adjust and you'll be able to see better in the dark.
Try not to play in the dark either.
Don't play in the dark, everybody.
Snake, you saw the turn radar.
Yeah.
I saw it.
I know.
I can't use it in a narrow space like this, right?
Right.
I'm sorry.
No reason to apologize.
Even the greatest masterpiece has its flaws.
Save.
I'll save.
Actually, no.
I'll do a new one.
Even though I don't want to go back and defeat Mantis again.
TrueBrainRod is casually saying, I got to get peed on first.
Like, that's a natural part of game progression.
But it is.
It is.
I can't believe that you're doing this.
Meiling, how did you get into this line of work?
The truth is I always wanted to become a fighter pilot.
I fell in love with jets watching them in the movies.
She's so cool.
You'd be surprised how many people say the same thing.
But I didn't want to kill people.
That's when I heard that the U.S.
Air Force needed people to do BDA's .
Those are the guys whose job it is to confirm how successful a bombing run was.
Yeah.
So I started to do research into aerial photography and accountability.
BBL?
No!
She's so smart.
I love it.
Just casually.
Isn't she like 16 or 17?
She's like, yeah, I was gonna become a fighter.
Like a, you know, a pilot.
I was gonna...
At her age.
Meryl, can you come pick me up?
I hate her.
Okay, anyway.
Okay, night vision goggles.
Okay, there's no dogs here.
Oh, he's gone.
Oh!
I'm trying to fight a dog.
Hold on.
Don't!
Don't eat me!
Is it this way?
I must punch the I must punch the dogs!
I must punch the dogs!
Punch the punch the punch, punch.
Punch punch punch punch.
Punch punch.
Oh, shit.
Where is the area?
Ow!
I'm gonna die here!
Because of the dogs!
Punch the dog!
Punch, punch punch.
Punch, punch, punch.
Punch, punch, punch Don't eat me!
Okay, that's what I mean.
Punch punch punch punch punch punch!
Punch punch!
Punch punch punch punch punch punch punch!
This is actually an ideal scenario.
This is the ideal scenario, you guys.
Punch punch punch punch punch punch!
Are they gonna...
Go and disappear!
Become little pixel people!
Oh, no...
Punch punch punch punch punch punch!
Punch punch!
Punch punch punch punch punch punch punch punch punch- ARGH!
Get out.
Punch punch, punch budge budge budge.
Oh my god!
Why do you have so much!
Is it here?
No it's not.
Get up get up snake.
Oh my god!
Oh my god you guys!
I'm in danger!
Where is the address?!
Oh by somehow- go snake, go.
Oh, I'm safe.
I'm safe.
Oh my god.
Wait, this isn't it, is it?
I got a ration, though.
Ah!
I can never find this damn exit!
Die, Zizzapam!
Uh-oh.
They knocked me into the cave with the wrong one!
There's just a baby looking at me!
Okay.
Wait, this other guy needs to go.
Ow!
Hey, hey!
Okay.
I think we can go.
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
Ah!
Are you kidding me?
I hate you.
I hate you, little dog.
Go, go, go!
Stay, go!
Please!
Please, stay, go!
Okay.
This is so messed up.
I thought the...
Yeah.
I thought so, too.
This is so messed up.
Meryl, they took all my rations!
They robbed me!
They robbed me blind.
Come on.
Give me piss immunity, please.
What do I do?
I have to hit her, right?
Yippee!
I fall!
Thank you for the five gifted.
Thank you.
What are you thinking?
I'm using my brain for real.
Okay.
Anyway.
We're all good.
Kind of.
Could be better, honestly.
Anyway, let's just go.
It's box A.
This place is mine.
I'll take point again.
Uh-oh.
Stay back, okay?
Wait.
The radar is working.
And since we can't use the mind detector either...
Leave it to me.
My mom is calling me.
Mom, stop calling me.
She actually wanted me to come see her today, but...
Oh, I gotta pay attention.
I'm just gonna crawl.
So, what do you think?
Pretty good, huh?
Pretty good.
How did you know where the mines were?
It sounds weird, but when Mantis dove into my mind, I was able to see where the mines were placed.
And I can run straight to her?
Are you impressed?
You can, but I always manage to mess it up anyway.
Only a little?
Just run straight up.
I always manage to get them anyway.
It's okay, though.
We'll just crawl and collect them all.
Is that all of them?
I think that's all of them.
Right?
I think so.
Probably.
Spee?
Whoa!
Merrill, they turned me into a Beyblade!
Merrill!
Okay,
I think we're good.
Anyway, don't get shot, Merrill.
Merrill, what is it?
Merrill, get down!
We said get down, Merrill!
Oh my goodness.
Girl.
Snake.
Leave me and run.
Merrill.
Yes.
I am a rookie after all.
Don't worry, Merrill.
It's me they want.
Even I know that.
It's the oldest trick in the book.
Yeah, pretty much.
Trying to lure you out.
Snipers just need for bait to lure you out.
Merrill.
Damn.
Shoot me, Snake.
No.
My gun.
I can't reach it by myself.
Don't move.
I promised.
I wouldn't slow you down.
I can still help.
I want to help you.
Quiet down.
Save your strength.
I was a fool.
I wanted to be a soldier.
But war is ugly.
There's nothing glamorous about it.
Snake, please save yourself.
Go on living and don't give up on people.
Don't forget me.
I like this part.
I like this part a lot.
Now get out of here.
Merrill.
Damn.
Snake.
It's a trap.
I like the ring when it's like all quiet.
The sniper's waiting for you to go and help Merrill.
And like Snake just being like, what do I do?
What do I do?
Don't do it.
Must be Sniper Wolf, Foxhound's best shooter.
Snipers usually work in pairs, but this one's alone, huh?
I know her.
She can wait for hours, days, or weeks.
It doesn't matter to her.
She's just watching and waiting for you to expose yourself.
Maybe so, but Merrill can't hold out that long.
Snake, can you see Wolf from where you are?
She wants me to expose myself?
There's nowhere to hide between here and the tower.
She must be on the second floor of the tower.
If Wolf is in the communications tower, she can see you perfectly.
It's the classic sniper's position.
Classic.
At that distance, you won't be able to hit her with a standard weapon either.
You'll need a sniper rifle.
Colonel, take it easy.
Take it easy.
I'm gonna save Merrill, no matter what it takes.
Okay.
Thanks.
What's wrong, Nail?
Nothing.
I'm just surprised you're willing to sacrifice yourself.
You've got the genes of a soldier not to save you.
I'm trying to save her.
I'm only interested in saving my own skin.
I wouldn't go that far, but...
I don't know what the hell my genes look like, and I don't care.
I operate on instinct, like an animal.
I'm going to save Merrill.
I don't need an excuse.
She's so rude!
And I'm not doing it for someone else, either.
I'm gonna save Merrill for myself.
You're so rude, Naomi.
Girl, don't worry.
Snake, thanks.
I understand.
I'm sorry.
Okay.
Um...
Let's leave.
Bye!
Okey-dokey.
Was there any other...
What's it called around here?
Any other places I can...
Excuse me?
What was that?
You can leave.
You can leave now.
I think if I get attacked by this dog without a ration on, I will actually die, so...
Um...
What's that?
Oh my god!
Please go away!
Yeah, let's go back to Merrill real quick.
That was really intense.
How are you so good at that?
Okey-dokey.
Let's go through first.
Surely the dogs are gone.
Okay.
Let's go through first.
Oh, shoot.
Ugh.
Box.
Okay.
Ah, stealth is optional in this game, you guys.
Stealth is optional.
Is it?
I don't actually know where the part or the area is.
Oh, we got some bulls.
Bullets.
I'll take that.
Okay.
Thank you, little puppies.
Thank you.
I know you love me so much.
I know.
I'm so cool.
I'm so kakoi.
I know.
You just really love me.
Okay.
Bye.
Cool.
Okey-dokey.
We have to go all the way back, baby.
To go get that P.S.
G.
Which...
I can't remember exactly where it was at.
I know.
It's in the second...
It's in the basement.
Oh, thank goodness.
Thank you.
Game.
You're so kind.
You're so...
Game.
Oh, game.
Sometimes you're so cruel and sometimes you're so kind.
Ask Otacon?
You're so right.
Wait.
Oh, shoot.
What was Otacon's frequency?
We haven't even called him once.
Wait.
What was Otacon's frequency?
Stay out of her range and shoot at her with a sniper rifle.
Yeah, but where can I find a sniper rifle?
I can't ask Meryl.
Is it 14112?
Okay.
He's been on the base for a while.
He might know.
Stay out of her range and shoot at her with a sniper...
Yeah.
Oh, there we go.
Hi, Otacon.
I was thinking that I was missing someone.
Otacon, have you ever seen a sniper rifle anywhere on this base?
A sniper rifle?
Meryl's been shot.
It is in the...
I'm an extremely good sniper.
It's where I didn't have to go before, but...
Sniper.
A high-quality sniper rifle is the only way I can fight back.
I saw a PSG-1 in the armory in the second-floor basement of the tank hangar.
The second-floor basement of the tank hangar?
I have to go all the way back there?
Yeah.
Well, yeah.
What's wrong?
What's wrong with you, Otacon?
Hmm?
Nothing.
Nothing, eh?
Yeah?
You want to elaborate, buddy?
Otacon.
Okay.
Hmm.
Master?
You need to make snap decisions.
In war, the difference between living and dying is counted in milliseconds.
Milliseconds.
Okay.
I don't think there's anything else in here.
Nope.
Oh my gosh, I keep thinking...
I keep getting the door wrong.
That guy is just peeing away.
Pew!
All righty.
Let's go to...
All the way back.
I'm also a box.
So glad nobody has to use this item.
Yep.
We'll just wait for this guy to walk on by.
I'm not even going to deal with him.
I'm just going to go.
We're going to...
Wait.
Now the field has...
Oh, shoot.
Wait.
Now the field has cameras, doesn't it?
Should I take the...
Should I try for the...
Okay.
Hold on.
Mei-Ling, I'm going to save.
Save?
Save.
What can I do for you, Snake?
Am I going to...
Maybe I'll try and take the truck.
In China, they say, rashness brings success to few, misfortune to many.
Is she telling me not to take the truck?
Snake, move forward when it's safe, but retreat when there's danger.
You'll just have to play it by ear, depending on the circumstances.
Okay.
Oh, gosh.
Oh,
gosh.
So, where the other guy is?
Oh, okay.
That was a camera.
He should be coming around any second, I feel.
I'm trying to look.
There we go.
Where is he?
Oh, there he is.
There he is.
Okay.
Don't move.
He's going to notice me, but he's going to say, just a box.
He's going to go, huh.
Just a box.
Oh, gosh.
You didn't even notice me.
What a dummy.
Oh, my gosh.
You're an idiot.
You're a dummy for real.
Okay, it's kind of tight here.
Never mind.
Not nearly as tight as I thought it was.
Just a box.
Okay, cool.
This is the right one, right?
Yeah.
Heliport.
Cool.
Just a box.
Stinky.
Smelly.
Really smelly box.
Is this all there is to load?
The heliport, huh?
Yep.
The heliport.
Thank you.
Yay.
I love it.
Twin snakes.
It's so...
You can see him so clearly in the box.
Oh, stinky.
Oh, this box smells so bad.
What is the boss putting in here?
Cool.
All righty.
There we go.
This guy's not asleep anymore.
Oh.
Oh my god.
Just a box.
Yeah.
Go that way.
Just a box.
Is there anything under here?
No.
Okay.
I'm sleepy.
Does this guy come back around too?
I hate that I...
I know I can't use it in narrow spaces.
Please don't notice me.
Perfect.
Isn't there...
I think there's also rations in here.
I didn't grab them earlier.
I don't think so.
Shadow Moses is E.P.'s soldier.
So E.P.
E.P.
guy.
Okay.
I feel asleep.
Yeah.
We're going to gather some supplies, everybody.
Okay.
Second floor basement.
I hate that area though.
I hate it because there's the trap doors and also the guys.
They always get me in there.
Every time.
How many rations do I have now?
Two, I think.
Three.
Hi.
Dog.
Let's go.
Meryl's incredible for surviving this long after being shot three times.
I'm convinced that as soon as you leave, she...
Sniper wolf grabs her and like starts treating her, right?
Because when you come back, she's gone.
So...
Okay.
I'm going to go.
I can't leave through this one.
Nope.
Got to be this one.
Spoilers?
Oh.
No.
I'm just saying.
I think that's what happens.
That's my...
That's...
You know.
Don't...
Don't trust me.
Thanks for the hot dogs.
Thank you.
See you later.
Is he upstairs or...
I can't tell.
The guy I'm hearing.
Is he upstairs or is he over here?
I can't tell.
I guess he's upstairs.
Hmm.
Until so much MG has brain rot, she doesn't realize when she's spoiling anymore.
No!
Don't say that!
Even me being like, don't spoil stuff, guys.
Box time.
Stinky.
He was looking over here.
Maybe not anymore.
Beep!
Was it B1?
Or B2?
Good luck, Min!
Thank you!
Wait, actually this will be a good place to grab some more supplies.
Wait, can I go in here?
Oh no!
I only have five!
This is six, isn't it?
Is there like supplies in here anymore?
Hello?
Yes!
Nice!
Okay, now...
I think there's another ration in here.
But I'm gonna use this one.
Which button?
B button.
Okay, there we go.
Nice, nice, nice.
Who's your favorite codec channel to talk to?
I don't know!
There's nothing under there, yeah.
Callie Master Miller.
Probably Master Miller.
Oh.
CQB!
I hate Master Miller.
It's CQC, Master Miller, you poser!
Oh!
Yeah, I knew that already.
Campbell, are you okay?
Are you freaking out a little bit?
A sniper rifle in the second-floor basement of the tank hangar?
Maybe.
Go get it!
And save Meryl!
Okay...sorry.
Oh...
Okay.
Sorry...
He's like, ahm...
Can you just do your job for 2 seconds?
Yeah, it's right there.
Nice!
Okay, with this we're basically...
topped off, which is great!
Alright.
My health is not a hundred percent, but it's pretty dang close.
And we have four rations, so let me grab anything that's in here as well.
Oh, what?
They blocked it?
Rude.
Never mind.
Second floor.
They were having rat issues.
Oh, yeah, probably.
Every time it gets me.
I think it's to the left over there, right?
I think it's this room right there.
I might be wrong, though.
I might be wrong.
I'm seeing how they walk around again.
I don't remember.
It says on the door.
Yeah, but we looked earlier.
I just can't remember.
This guy down here just walks past... I think it has to be this one because he is constantly walk...
Look at this!
He's camping it!
It has to be this one.
This guy down here is completely camping.
Oh, there's three guys.
Okay.
Oh, he's like... Wait, turn around and walk away, please.
Okay, I'm gonna have to... I think I'm gonna have to choke him out.
Wait, is this guy... This guy's gonna come down, right?
Yeah, he goes down.
He goes down that way.
Okay, okay, okay.
It has to be this one.
Oh, gosh.
Okay.
I'm waiting for him to leave a little bit more.
I think I'll be able to get him once he turns around now.
Oh, shit!
I had my weapon equipped!
Just a box!
Oh, no, but they're back.
Okay.
Is this a slidey... Wait, hold on.
Where's my cigarette at?
Oh, it's... Oh, it's awkward.
Oh, it's weird.
Okay.
Let's... Let's unequip this.
If I mess up...
Oh, well... Just kill me.
Just kill me.
It's okay.
We can start from this floor again.
Like that!
Okay, once this guy goes down, though, I can leave.
If I mess up, he immediately messes up.
Look, okay?
Look.
I don't... I don't... I don't have any excuses.
Oh, the thing didn't even go off.
Okay.
Unequip.
Oh!
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Wait!
My... My right trigger is not working, you guys!
My right trigger is not working!
Hold on.
Um...
Uh-oh.
Uh-oh, uh-oh.
Uh-oh, uh-oh, uh-oh, uh-oh.
My left trigger is working.
My right trigger...
is not working!
I have to unequip the box first?
Are you sure?
Okay, hold on.
I just want... I know he can't see me.
But I... I don't trust it anyway.
Oh, you're right.
Oh my gosh, you're right.
Okay, it's fine now.
Ugh!
Oh my gosh, that scared me.
That scared me so bad.
Whew!
Go, go, go, go, go!
Oh, dang!
Um, I'm also gonna...
shoot at you.
Don't call me!
You got a PSG-1!
Yes, I did!
You can use that against Sniper Wolf!
I'm gonna go!
Hurry up and save Meryl!
I'm gonna... I'm hurrying!
Oh, uh, I'm hurrying.
Yes, I am.
Run, Snake, run!
Oh, I can't get out of here.
Uh...
Ah!
Just run?
Oh my gosh.
Uh, now I have to wait for the...
Elevator!
Please.
Oh my gosh.
I can't use it.
I can't use it until I'm good.
Goodbye, rations.
Bye, rations.
Why is everything against me?
Huh?
Just a box!
You don't see anything.
Don't turn this way.
Oh, my goodness.
Oh, God.
Anyway, we're out.
If that guy hadn't yelled for no reason, all he was doing was choking him, why did he yell about it?
Stupid guy!
Why did he have to yell?
Oh!
Why did he have to yell about getting killed?
What an idiot.
This should have been a really quiet, peaceful death.
There's still a guy in there.
Huh.
Hold on.
I'm waiting for this.
I think he can't see me.
I'm gonna un-equip my weapon too.
Like a glove.
Ugh.
Okay.
Let's go back to the heliport.
Oh, there's a guy.
Let's go back.
How many rations info have left?
Only two!
I'm feeling like I should do it over.
If only I hadn't messed up the alarm before.
It would have been fine.
It's all my fault.
If only I hadn't messed up the alarm.
But it's so hard.
It's so hard getting in there.
That's such a tight squeeze!
Oh!
There will be more rations in the future.
Yeah, I know.
But I like having full rations.
Wait.
Oh, there.
I was like, wait a second.
Here, here.
Just gonna chill out right here.
Wait for these guys to walk away.
And then we'll get into the car.
What the heck was he doing?
Not gonna turn around, are you?
That's what I thought.
Wait.
And to the nuclear warhead building.
Is this all there is to load?
Maybe we can go loot the area with the gas.
Maybe there's stuff in there too.
We can go loot the area with the gas.
I think.
There's bullets and stuff over there.
I need it.
Chaff grenade.
Nice.
I think that guy went up.
He doesn't turn around here, right?
Yeah.
Beep.
Hurry, hurry, hurry.
Wait, was it one or two?
I think it was two.
It was two.
Oopsie.
Hold on.
We're gonna go loot a little bit.
My guys.
My bad.
Okay.
Here we go.
Cause there's no one in here.
There's only...
Look, look, and there's...
Look!
There's stuff!
I need it.
I can chaff in here.
Probably.
And gas mask.
And...
Chaff grenade.
Run, run, run, run, run, run, run.
Run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run.
Chaff!
Oh, yeah, blah, blah.
There we go.
Beep, beep!
More chaff.
Nice.
Chaff.
If
I take off the gas mask, my O2 just goes down faster.
But...
I need...
Actually, can I...
Is there stuff...
I can't even tell if there's stuff in here.
You know what?
Let's just leave.
This is good... enough.
It's good enough.
I don't want to waste too many chaff grenades either.
Okay.
Now let's go.
Only some of the text is in Japanese?
Yeah!
Because Integral was never released for US.
But you can change it to the text of the cutscenes to be in English and stuff.
And the codex.
But...
Yeah, the text for the actual items are in Japanese.
I will!
I'm gonna go!
Master, what do you think?
If you can get out of a jam using just your hands and feet, then do it.
If you can't, then go for the gun.
Thanks, Master.
You're so wise.
This guy's trying to kill me.
Don't give me the silent treatment, mister!
What can I do for you, Snake?
Campbell is like... she's related?
She's her... it's his niece!
That is related!
By a little bit of blood.
Tiny blood.
Relation.
Whoa.
No, I'm cautious.
Maybe a little overly so.
Hahaha.
Was there anything with the guy peeing?
Does you give me... will you give me a ration?
Oh, give me some bullets.
Okay.
Nothing in here.
Dang.
Oh!
Guy was just peeing.
Way too loudly.
I do feel bad, like, taking him out when he is on the bathroom.
Like... or on the toilet, I guess.
Nothing... Oh!
It does respawn!
This place is amazing!
Yippee!
Does this stuff respawn here, too?
Oh, Meryl.
You were right over... Oh!
You guys were all good!
That's where she was.
Oh my gosh.
Oh!
No dogs here.
None, actually.
We're good.
It was box A.
5, 6, 7, 0, 9!
Au!
Oh, uh, thank you.
Love you, too.
Oh, you're just one of my fans, huh?
Yeah, one of my fans, one of my fans.
Is it here?
Oh gosh, wait.
Hold on.
No, no, it's...
It's there.
Okay, I'm gonna need you guys to, like...
Get back a little.
Here, let's lead him over here.
Come here, come here.
Oh, I'll take that, actually.
That's pretty good to have.
Come over here.
Okay.
There we go, there we go.
Oh.
We are following Mint Robot and Off Guy.
Stop!
Okay, good dog.
Sit, sit.
Good boy, good boy.
Good boy, good boy, good boy.
Sit, sit, sit.
And sit.
Good boy, good boy.
Stay.
No, no, no.
Okay.
Oh, shoot.
Where is it?
Here.
Okay.
Okay, okay.
We're good, we're good, we're good.
Nice!
I always... I was gonna say, I always thought there was a rash in here.
And there is!
Okay.
Very good.
Alright.
Time for a battle.
Oh.
Wrong button.
Mei... Well, I guess it doesn't really matter, but...
Yeah, I'm just gonna say, if I'm being caught...
You know...
Psycho Mantis kinda got to me, too.
She said I was risky.
I don't feel that way.
I just wanna talk to Mei Ling more.
Make sure that you're not thinking of something else during the mission.
Okay?
Okay.
Stay out of her range and shoot at her with a sniper rifle.
I'm not so good at this one, I think.
Because the...
It's hard to...
I just feel like it's hard when she...
is... Okay, we got the Diza as a Pam.
Um...
Alright, hold on.
PSG1.
It's always hard for me to get an angle here.
I mean...
It's...
That's my...
That's the toughest part for me.
Is how to get the angle here.
Without getting...
Look!
Without getting shot by her!
Uh...
Like, what is...
What is the good strategy here?
Like...
Angel or angle?
Angle!
Like, what's the...
What's the...
Just raw dog it.
No!
Go further back.
But she can see me.
Right?
She'll be able to see me back there.
What's the best way?
Just run out and aim quick?
Oh, gosh.
Spray and pray.
That's not really an option here, is it?
Press against the wall and you can see when she's aiming.
You can.
Oh!
Look at this!
She knows exactly where I am!
Oh!
She gave up.
I thought...
I thought she never gives up.
I thought she'll be here for months, for weeks, forever.
I thought she just lives and breathes this part, you know?
She knows exactly where I am, though.
Maybe...
Hold on.
When she turns around...
Or when she gives up...
I'm gonna run to the other side.
Oh!
She totally saw where I went.
Didn't even matter.
Oh, my God.
Is that...
Are those the little rats upstairs?
Do you see them moving around?
They're so cute.
They're just little...
Actually, one pixels of rats.
That's so funny.
Okay.
So, where was she at?
Where'd she go?
Okay.
She's behind the pillar.
Oh!
Whoa!
It's so slow!
Why is it so slow?
Oh, it's because of me.
Don't hit me.
Don't hit.
This...
This one is so annoying to me.
Again.
Because it's like...
How the heck...
How the heck do I get to her?
I don't know.
Okay.
Maybe I take a disazepam here.
Shoot.
Oh, shoot.
I mean...
I need to shoot.
Where are you?
Oh.
There we go.
You know.
This time is the charm.
Can I get her hand?
No.
Oh.
Ouch!
Oh, my God.
Denver.
Hey,
November.
December.
I just changed this.
You missed our management meeting.
Take that.
Okay.
Edit this.
I wasrn't I..
Shut..
Wait.
Oh, I for..
I'm sorry about this.
You really...
Stop shooting me!
I'm trying to get into position!
Yeah!
Get out!
Don't do it!
Even if I can just get her...
She missed.
Oh my god!
How did that miss?
I'm sorry!
What?
How did that miss?
Come on.
That was one pixel off.
That's crazy.
She's gonna run back.
I just... I just got back here!
If this is the battle I have to do again, I'm gonna scream.
Where is she even?
That was me.
That was all me.
I can't believe I did that!
Oh my gosh.
Sniper wolf, please!
These controls... I'm trying to get as little of movement as...
There we go.
They're so awkward, the controls.
I know.
I got her too, though.
I only have three bullets left!
Wait.
Uh-oh.
I only have three bullets left.
That's no good, is it?
Make them count.
Yeah, for sure.
Three bullets.
Okay.
And not a lot of dis-dis-a-pam left either.
Oh my god.
I'm so slow!
I'm so slow at turning!
I just turned!
Please, sniper wolf, please!
Wait, where is she?
Uh-oh.
It's okay.
Okay.
The controls here are so awkward.
Alrighty.
We got this!
No need to worry about bullets.
Yeah, right?
So true!
Okay.
Alright.
And, uh...
Looks like you're redoing this one.
Yeah, that's okay, though.
I'm not gonna get all of them.
Oh my gosh.
Please, though.
If I could just get in a decent angle when I, like, initially start, it'll save me...
so much, you know?
There we go.
That's better.
Okay.
Where is she?
Oh!
Shoot.
Oh my god.
Don't shoot me.
Got
her?
Okay.
I don't know how I managed that one, to be honest.
Sometimes her hitbox is...
Ouch!
Oh, I need to put on my rations again.
Oh, shoot.
No, no, no.
Going to this side.
How many bullets do I have?
I clicked it.
Come on.
Show your face.
Show your face!
This side?
What the hell?
Got her?
Aiming at her just a little bit.
Oh my god.
There we go.
Come on.
Can't get me from here.
What a shooting pose.
Okay.
That was a good position.
Oh my god.
I'm Beyblading again.
Sniper wolf won't be able to hit me if I...
Fly at her like this.
Oh my god.
Okay.
All right.
It should be good.
Okay.
And...
Guys, it's Pam.
Come on.
Oh my god.
Please.
No!
I forgot to equip my rations again.
Oh, it's the switching between it.
I had her.
It's the switching.
Dang it.
I forgot to.
Oh, I forgot to.
Dang it.
This is...
It's funny that this is the one causing me the most grief right now.
And I say grief very lightly.
Like I'm...
I don't...
It's only...
Whatever.
Oh.
Can you get up, Snake?
It's only the third time.
I'll try.
It's just a little bit annoying.
Oh!
Okay.
There we go.
All right.
Guys, is it...
Russian?
Headshot!
Oh, dang it.
Oh.
Oh, she got me too.
Run.
Shoot.
No, stop.
Let me get into position, please.
Okay.
Don't hit.
Oh.
Oh my god.
Where is she?
I think she's behind me.
There she is.
Yeah.
I got you too.
Oh.
No.
Yeah.
That's right.
Can I get her from here?
Yeah.
Oh.
Ouch!
How did you get me even?
It's just...
Getting into position is so hard for me.
Oh.
She tried.
Oh my god.
Don't.
Don't shoot.
Okay.
Good.
Nice.
Yippee.
Are the cameras here yet?
I can't remember.
Take that.
There's one what?
One down here, right?
Maybe not.
Time to take a little bit of stuff.
A little bit.
Yippee.
Take some what?
Some bullets.
Please.
Thank you.
I'll take that.
Oh.
What else is around here?
Over there?
I'm a gamer?
I'm a soldier.
Call Mei Ling?
Oh.
Mei Ling, I did it.
Snake, wouldn't now be a good time to save your mission?
What's going on?
Oh.
She's got a bad feeling.
I'm getting a bad feeling.
Oh.
Bad feeling.
Like a premonition or something.
A premonition.
She's so smart.
Oh.
Snake, it's all up to you.
I love when she says that and there's no BGM.
You just have like the...
You know, you just have the wind and stuff.
It's so creepy.
It's so unnerving.
Good job with Wolf.
Is Meryl okay?
I don't know.
I don't see her around.
You don't think she's been captured, do you?
Could be.
Let's ask Wolf.
If she's still alive, I'm going to get some answers.
Snake.
About Meryl.
I'm counting on you.
Snake.
Yeah.
Master, what do you have to say about me being a gamer?
Snake, divide and conquer.
Try to take your enemies on one at a time.
Okay.
I haven't talked to Nastasha in a while.
Let's see what she says.
It is so ironic.
People are working as slaves to pay for weapons that must never be used.
She's once again off topic.
Love that for her.
Love you, Nastasha.
Oh.
He doesn't even talk to me at all.
Come on.
Come on, Otacon.
Oh, I like the blood drops here.
That's like a good attention to detail.
That's so cool.
And also the ones going down the stairs, so you could tell.
I mean, she's not there.
She must have escaped.
Right?
Hmm.
Okay.
Nastasha.
Oh.
I don't even have a level six key.
I wouldn't even be able to get past.
It's hard to miss when you're this close.
Toss your weapon over here.
Slowly.
No.
Don't take my weapon.
You are a fool to come back here.
Stupid man.
Oh.
Ladies.
Sniper, huh?
Oh.
Ladies.
Sniper.
Didn't you know that two-thirds of the world's greatest assassins are women?
You tell him.
Do you want to die now?
Or after your female friend?
Ooh.
Which will it be?
I'll die after I kill you.
Oh.
Is that right?
Well, at least you've got spirit.
I am Sniper Wolf.
And I always kill what I aim at.
She is so awesome.
Oh.
You are a man.
My special prey.
I like how my controller vibrated when she grabbed my face.
Oh.
I've left my mark on you.
I won't forget it.
Until I kill you, you're all I think about.
Oh my god.
I got knocked out by a lady.
Take her away.
Yippee.
Can you be as awesome as Sniper Wolf?
No.
I don't think so.
Don't kill me yet.
I'm too alive.
Leave it to me.
Oh.
Yeah.
We're gonna leave it to you?
Oh.
I saw that.
Yes.
He's my target.
Mine.
Her accent is so beautiful.
Oh.
Hello.
Here he is...
dois snake.
He's tougher than I thought.
Do you know who I am?
No.
I always knew that one day I would meet you.
Where are you?
The man who stole what was rightly mine.
The man who stole my birthright.
If you mash too fast during the torture, it'll trigger the auto-firefly.
I don't think I've ever mashed that hard enough.
Forget it.
Wow, you kinky man!
Mia, I'm the man you stole everything good from.
Oh, my eyes.
And now, after the sacrifice of our brothers, after thirty long years, finally, the two of us meet.
Brothers.
The brother of light and the brother of dark.
Let me out!
Do you need his DNA too?
Yes.
Ooh!
I want a sample while he's still alive.
We need it to correct the Genome Soldier's mutations.
Then we'll be able to cure them.
No, we still have to get our hands on Big Boss's DNA.
They suffer from stupid...
Hey, show yourself!
Come on!
Have they given in to our demands yet?
Not yet.
They won't give in.
They're all hypocrites.
Every one of them.
Is that your opinion has occurred?
They always put politics first.
That's right.
That's why they want to avoid any leak about their precious new nuclear weapon.
Boss, it looks like our friend is awake.
I've been awake!
Oh, thank you.
Oh!
Hi, Liquid.
There definitely is a resemblance.
Don't you think, little brother?
Or should I say, big brother?
I'm not sure.
Anyway, it doesn't matter.
Who came out first?
You and I are both the last surviving sons of Big Boss.
It's me.
Really?
Then what?
Those idiots!
Uh-oh.
All right, Raven.
I'll be right there.
They're not responding to our demands.
Oh, my God.
We launch the first one in ten hours as planned.
Damn Americans.
Oh, my God.
Looks like you read them wrong.
Something's funny.
Normally, the Americans are the first ones to the negotiating table.
They must think they've got something up their sleeves.
So it's come down to it, hasn't it?
I was about to say, they think they have an ace up their sleeves.
Going to launch that nuke and ride it all the way into history.
I've got to take care of some launch preparations.
You're in charge here, Ocelot.
What about you?
Want to stay for the show?
I'm not interested.
It's time to feed the family.
She's got to take her dessert as a pen.
So you prefer your wolves to my show, huh?
Yeah.
Ocelot, don't screw up like you did with the Chief.
Yes, I know.
That was an accident.
I didn't think a pencil pusher like him would be so tough.
Well, his mental defenses were reinforced by hypnotherapy.
Boss, what about that mink?
He's killed twelve men.
But he died in the cell.
Bastard took my hand.
How could he have gotten in here?
Perhaps there's a spy among us.
Among us?
We've also got to find out what killed Baker and Octopus.
We're short-handed, so make this little torture show of yours as short as possible.
I can't wait to fight him.
This is an interrogation.
As you wish.
See you later, brother.
Short-handed.
Your woman is still in this world.
Merl.
Catch you later, handsome.
Once she picks a target, she doesn't think about anything else.
Sometimes she even falls in love with him before she kills him.
These camera angles.
Finally, just the two of us.
Just the two of us.
How are you feeling?
We can make it.
Not bad.
Cut a nice nap on this revolving bed of yours.
Try.
Too bad I was sleeping alone.
Glad to hear that.
This is some bed, all right.
I'm about to show you some of its nicer features.
Snake, you little flirt.
Flirt with anyone that moves.
Oh, don't worry.
They're all there.
Washington was taking quite a chance sending you here.
Someone must have had a lot of faith in your skill, huh, carrier boy?
Carrier boy.
So, Metal Gear is armed with a new type of nuclear warhead, huh?
Why don't you go ask Campbell for the full story?
Colonel?
The Colonel?
By the way, you got an optical disc from President Baker, didn't you?
What if I did?
Is that the only disc?
There's no other data?
What do you mean?
There's no copy?
If not, that's fine.
Is Meryl okay?
I don't even know how to turn on turbo.
Wolf must have been feeling generous.
Maybe he wanted to stay that way.
You better start answering my questions right now.
Okay.
You were holding one card key.
Yeah.
Where are the other two?
What's the trick behind that key?
I don't know.
Trick?
That weasel of a president said there's some kind of trick to using the key.
Or treat.
Well, if I know...
I see.
No problem then.
We're going to play a game, Snake.
A game?
We'll find out what kind of man you really are.
When the pain becomes too great to bear.
Just give up and your suffering will end.
Just give up?
What if you do?
The girl's life is mine.
No!
Are you going to fight or submit?
I'm going to fight.
Press the circle button repeatedly to regain your strength.
It says B even.
When you've had enough, press the select button to select.
I... I said in the, uh... Carol and talk.
Hell no.
I don't even think about using auto-fire.
How do you even use that?
W.
You're a hostage.
There's no Geneva Convention.
No one is coming to save you.
Starting to feel a little scared?
No.
Good.
You should be.
He doesn't even say anything hostile.
I said this in the first stream of this.
But because I'm playing through, like, the series...
I, um...
I decided that I want to play...
The, um... the...
How did you like that?
True ending, rather, you know?
Shall we go again?
So that's why I'm gonna play it.
Oh, my God.
Hold on.
I'm gonna put it on the desk.
We're not finished yet.
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay, okay.
Now it's not in my lap.
Okay.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
My fingers.
You're a strong man.
Well, that's enough for now, huh?
That will help.
Thank you guys for the breeze.
You're the boss's brother, all right.
Your brother, he's an amazing man.
Who else could shoot down two F-16s with a hind helicopter?
The Les Enfanterie Project was not a total failure.
He is the one man who could make my dream into a reality.
Nice suit.
Who's dragging me away?
My stuff.
Give me my stuff.
Les Enfanterie.
Looks like I got a roommate.
Oh, gross.
The DARPA chief.
The DARPA chief?
Why'd they keep him in here?
What a stench.
Nasty.
Looks like he's been dead for days.
Damn.
I gotta go.
That witch.
She took my clothes.
Shut up in there, will ya?
Snake.
Are you okay?
I've been better.
I love that he's naked in the codec.
Damn.
Snake, the government has decided not to give in to their demands.
Yeah, I heard.
We're trying to buy some more time.
Okay.
Come on, Colonel.
Why don't you stop playing dumb?
I'm sorry about Meryl, but I want the lies to end now.
What are you talking about?
Metal Gear was designed to launch a new type of nuclear warhead, wasn't it?
It was.
You knew it all along, didn't you?
Colonel.
I'm so disappointed in you.
Why did you try to hide it?
I'm sorry.
Colonel.
Can't tell the grunts, huh?
You've changed a lot.
Metal Gear.
Secret advanced nuclear weapons research.
Does the White House know about this?
How deep does it go?
As far as I know, as of yesterday, the President had not been briefed about the Rex project.
Need to know basis.
Is that the idea?
These are sensitive times.
Even subcritical nuclear tests are causing quite a stir.
Plausible deniability, huh?
Yes.
And tomorrow, the President and his Russian counterpart are scheduled to sign the START III accord.
I get it.
That's the reason for the deadline.
That's right, Snake.
And that's why we can't let this terrorist attack go public.
We still haven't even ratified START II, or dealt with the issue of TMDs.
TMDs?
This has to do with the President's reputation, and America's place as the dominant superpower.
So patriotism is your excuse for circumventing?
Yippee, more MDS!
Thank you!
Why should I?
Because you're the only one who can.
In that case, tell me the truth about this new type of nuclear warhead.
I told you before, I don't know the details.
I don't believe you.
If the situation is so serious, why don't you give in to their demands?
Let them have Big Boss' remains.
You see?
Or is there some reason that you can't do that?
Snake, I don't know.
What?
Publicly, the President has been very vocal in his opposition to eugenics experiments.
Right.
You don't want the existence of the Genome Army to go public.
And that's the only reason?
Oh, come on.
You coward!
Hell with you.
I'm sorry.
You coward!
The corpse of the DARPA chief is lying right here next to me.
Oh, man.
But it's strange.
He looks and smells like he's been dead for days.
All his blood's been drained out, too.
Whoa.
Drained.
I'm sorry.
Maybe to slow down decomposition?
I have no idea.
But the chief only died a few hours ago, right?
Uh, yeah.
Right.
But he's already started to decompose.
Weird.
What could it all be about?
Something in his blood that they wanted?
I doubt it.
Just the nanomachines and the transmitter.
Did the chief tell them his detonation code?
I'm afraid so.
Apparently, yeah.
It looks like they've got both codes and are nearly ready to launch.
Dun dun.
Is there any way to prevent it?
It seems that there's some type of threat.
Maybe there's some type of emergency override device that can cancel out the detonation code.
It's a countermeasure that Arms Tech installed secretly.
Nanomachines.
In his blood.
You have to unlock it with three special card keys.
And where are those keys?
I've got one of them.
Maybe there's a bisexual afoot.
I don't know where the other two are.
Besides, I'm locked up here.
We've got no choice.
Forget about the keys.
Your top priority now is to destroy Metal Gear itself.
Okay.
Sorry to have to lay it all in your lap, but you're all I've got.
Lost out of there.
Well, maybe you should be more honest with me.
I'm the one who's gonna destroy the Kishin's Tower.
Also...
What?
You're asking for a whole lot.
Yeah.
Colonel.
I'll save her.
Thanks.
Wow.
How's Master doing?
Normally, when a soldier is taken prisoner, he should only give up the big four.
The big four?
That's name, rank, serial number, and date of birth.
Oh.
But you're not any old soldier, Snake.
Why those things?
I don't want to be a prisoner.
I don't want you to tell them anything.
Oh, okay.
Fortunately, you're strong enough to resist.
Yeah.
Uh...
Nastasha?
Just because you are locked up does not mean there is no chance of escape.
Keep your eyes and ears open.
And when you see a chance, take it.
Take it.
Otacon, come get me out of here.
Otacon, are you still okay?
Yeah.
Thanks to the stealth.
I'm fine.
It's a stealth camouflage, that is.
I have a favor to ask.
I need your help.
I was wondering when you'd ask.
What should I do?
I've been captured.
I'm locked up here in this cell.
What cell?
There's a big torture machine nearby.
Okay.
I know it.
It's close.
I'll be there right away.
Why do you know this?
Why do you know the torture machine, Otacon?
Why did you...
Okay, first of all, you were like, I think I'm making things for good.
I'm making machines to be like my Japanese animes.
But then you see the giant torture device, and you're just like, what?
I was like, these are the good guys.
Why'd you...?
What's up with that?
Bless you.
Shut up in there, will you?
Shut up.
No kink-shaming.
Sorry, sorry.
I'm not kink-shaming, I'm not kink-shaming.
I have to do it another time, right?
To get... I want to try the ketchup.
Shut up in there, will ya?
Bless you.
Shut up.
Look at his... he's got such range for his vision.
Sniper wolf in him, he used the torture device.
It's showtime!
Okay.
Alright.
My finger has been given enough time maybe to recover.
Okay.
Yes.
I will use it repeatedly to regain your strength.
Okay.
When you've had enough, press the select button to submit.
When your life reaches zero, the game is over.
There are no continues, my friend.
And he means it.
I've fought wars in Afghanistan, Mozambique, Eritrea, and Chad.
Among the mujahideen guerrillas, I was known and feared as...
Shamashaska.
I was trained by the Russian rules.
Hahaha.
I am not like one of those KGB slugs.
To me, this isn't torture.
It's a sport.
You're all just a bunch of sadists.
Don't confuse me with those uniformed fools.
Oh my god, you're such a freak.
Shall we begin?
Okay.
Shamashaska.
Okay, here we go.
Okay, here we go, here we go, guys.
Shamashaska.
You know
why I think it's more difficult for me this time?
How did you like that?
The buttons are bigger.
Shall we go again?
When I did it on the PS1 controller last time, it was so much easier.
Because the buttons were more shallow.
Had enough yet?
We're not finished yet.
Yeah.
Okay.
Here we go.
Three.
You're a strong man.
Well, that's enough for now.
Thank you.
Thank you, Aslan.
We live in a sad age.
In a society.
Imperialism, totalitarianism, perestroika.
20th century Russia has had its share of problems.
But at least they had an ideology.
Russia today has nothing.
They're struggling between freedom and order.
And with that struggle, a new spirit of nationalism has been born.
The boss has a close friend high up in the Russian government.
He's currently the head of Spetsnaz.
Who could that be?
He's agreed to purchase this new nuclear weapons system.
The hind was just a down payment.
So you're in this for money?
I don't need money.
I want Russia to be reborn.
Yeah.
To lead a brave new world order.
That's why he's doing it.
No.
We got you.
We got you, Ocelot.
Bye.
So do I have to do it one more time or...
Am I good now?
I guess we wait for him to go to the bathroom right?
Otacon, where are you?
Otacon...
I'm headed your way now...
Can't you just relax?
This is life or death.
I am relaxed.
I just don't know how to kill time here.
Okay.
I'll be there as soon as I can.
I am relaxed.
You okay, Snake?
Yeah.
Nothing new to report.
Three equals dead.
Is there anything I can do?
Yeah.
My arm hurts.
Poor Snake.
I increased the level of painkillers in your blood.
Okay, but you can leave out the Benzedrine.
That stuff makes me too frisky.
I guess you're not feeling too bad after all.
Snake, put the controller up against your arm.
Okay.
What?
Don't worry.
It'll feel good.
It's up against my arm?
Huh?
Okay.
Here I go.
That felt good.
How does it feel, Snake?
A little better?
Yeah.
How did you do that?
I stimulated your muscle fibers with the nanomachine cilia.
Wow.
That's about all I can do for you.
Naomi, please talk to me.
Say something to take my mind off the pain.
This guy.
What can I say?
Anything.
I... I'm not a very good talker.
Naomi, please.
Tell me about yourself.
Myself?
That's a tough one.
Any family?
That's not a happy topic for me.
I don't have any family.
No.
Wait.
There was a man who said he was my father.
Where is he?
Dead.
By my own hand.
Big Boss.
What?
Big Boss?
I had no idea.
There was no way you could.
It happened in Zanzibar six years ago.
Only six years ago?
Only Snake and I know the real truth of what happened there.
He was so green back then.
So, is it true?
Was Big Boss really your father?
That's what he said.
That's all I know.
And you were able to kill him?
Knowing that?
Yup.
Besides, some people just need killing.
That's petricide.
Yup.
That's the trauma that Mantis was talking about.
The one we share in common.
Is that why you left Foxhound?
Let's just say that I needed to be alone for a while.
And Alaska was the perfect place.
Snake.
I didn't have a real family either.
Just a big brother who put me through school.
We weren't even blood related and he was much older than me.
Where is he?
He's dead.
I'm sorry.
Sorry, I'm messaging Matara at the same time.
Snake.
We're trying to figure out when to record.
After you've been through as many wars as me, it's hard to trust anyone.
Friends?
Friends.
Roy Campbell.
You're still calling me friend?
Barely.
No.
There was another.
Frank Yeager.
What?
Big Boss's most trusted lieutenant.
And the only member of Foxhound ever to receive the code name Fox.
Grey Fox.
I learned a lot from him.
But... but... but...
Didn't you try to kill each other?
That's true.
Grey Fox!
We did it.
In Zanzibar.
But it was nothing personal.
We were just professionals on opposite sides.
That's all.
And you still call yourself friend?
Hard to believe.
War is no reason to end a friendship.
That's crazy.
That's insane.
Oh no, it's the first time I've agreed with Naomi.
He was being held a prisoner of outer heaven.
But he didn't look like a prisoner to me.
He was always so cool and precise.
I was still green.
And he showed me the ropes.
You knew him well?
No.
We never talked about our personal lives.
Sort of an unwritten rule.
We just were buddies.
We were war buddies.
The next time I saw you on the battlefield, we were enemies.
We were fighting barehanded in a minefield.
Yeah.
I did that once.
I know it sounds strange to most people.
But we were just two soldiers doing our jobs.
It's like a sport.
You sound like Ocelot.
We were wild animals.
You're right.
We are animals.
Just dudes being dudes.
So if you were friends, then how do you explain the ninja's behavior?
I don't know.
It's your genes.
They make you predispose towards violence.
You really like talking about genes, Naomi.
Why did you get into genetic research anyway?
Gosh, you don't shut up about genes, Naomi.
I guess I got into genetics because I wanted to figure out why I am the way I am.
Annoying?
Yeah.
I thought if I studied my genetic structure, I'd find out who I really was.
I thought that by analyzing a person's genetic information, I could retrieve the brain.
You can even find blank spots in that person's memory.
Memory is stored in DNA.
We're not sure, but we know that a person's genetic fate is determined just by the sequence of the four bases in their DNA.
So what about my fate?
You know my DNA is sequenced, don't you?
Your fate?
I'm sorry, I have no idea.
Of course not.
You're a scientist, not a fortune teller.
Why'd you say it like that, though?
Can bromance bloom on the battlefield?
Master!
Don't say anything to tease or anger the person torturing you.
If you make him mad, it'll be that much worse for you.
You'll need to save your strength.
I'm gonna tease him?
Ooh la la.
Otacon, where the hell are you?
I'm headed your way now.
Can't you just relax?
Where are you?
Hey.
Shut up in there, will ya?
Shut up.
Oh no.
There he goes!
Oh
god.
Okay.
I'm glad this place is pretty soundproof, so...
Oh?
Hey.
I'm here.
Hey!
Oh.
I can't see you.
It's me.
Otacon.
Otacon?
They even capture you.
Hurry.
Get me out of here.
Get me out of here!
Let me go.
That hurts.
Hurry up.
Yes.
Is that how you ask a guy a favor?
Oh my god.
They're so close.
Let me go.
Jeez.
It's like an animal's cage.
Why is everybody comparing me to an animal today?
I don't wanna smell.
Because of him.
Yeah.
Stinker.
Stinker over there.
It's the Derpachief.
The Derpachief?
You don't have enough to get me out of here.
I'll be laying next to him.
The Derpachief.
You bastard.
This lock won't open with a security guard.
You killed Kennen.
You need a key like a soldier's cap.
Those bastards.
So what are you doing here, then?
I thought you might be hungry.
If you need more food, I can bring some more later.
Tiny ration.
Also, I got you this level six card.
It'll get you out of that torture room.
Yes.
Here.
Take this, too.
What's this?
It's a handkerchief.
I got it from Sniper Wolf.
Why?
I don't know why, but she's nice to me.
Why are you giving it to him, though?
Sounds like Stockholm Syndrome to me.
What does Otacon eat?
I was taking care of the dogs here.
After the terrorists...
I guess if you're eating rations, putting ketchup on it could help, right?
But Sniper Wolf stopped them.
She even let me feed them when I asked.
Aww.
She likes dogs.
She must be a good person.
So true.
Please don't hurt her.
Wake up, you idiot.
She's the one who shot Meryl.
She likes dogs.
Well, that's all I can do.
She likes animals.
They're planning to launch a nuke.
I've got to stop them.
Then you have to get past the communications.
I'm going to have to go.
I'm going to the communications tower.
First, you have to get me out of here.
Come on.
I'm trying my best.
That guard's got the key.
You'll have to take him out.
Him?
Give me a break.
I'm no soldier.
I can't take anybody out.
Okay.
You have to.
That's a lot to ask.
I'll be killed.
He's coming back.
Oh, jeez.
See you later.
Bye.
Wait.
Okay.
Catch up.
Oh, jeez.
What?
I don't...
Oh, B button.
Okay.
Here I go.
We're just going to not worry about this next part.
Okay?
What the...
We're just going to not worry about this next part.
Okay?
Oh.
Oh my God.
Come here.
Come on.
We're just gonna not worry about that.
What just happened.
Okay?
Everything's good.
We're just gonna...
We're just gonna not worry about that, okay?
Everybody, it's fine.
Everybody, it's all good.
Where is my stuff at?
Let's go get changed.
Did you just kill Johnny?
No, no, no.
Hold on the bomb for a call.
Yes, I actually was going to mention that.
I actually was going to say, I know that there is a bomb in my inventory.
But, I'm going to hold on to it.
For some funny cutscene, or funny codex stuff that I wanna see.
Not funny, but some codex stuff I wanna see.
To get to the underground base where Metal Gear is, you'll have to climb the communications tower.
On the north side of the cave.
Okay.
Now that you've got your stuff back, you should take a good look through it.
If you're slow equipping an item in battle, it could mean death.
Shush.
The future will be changed.
You've created a time paradox.
I said, everything's fine, you guys.
Everything's all good.
Everything's fine.
So, you figured out what I had in mind, huh?
I can't believe it actually worked.
He's such a genius!
Oh, it was auto contact the whole time.
Johnny has a really strong neck.
Okay, um...
What else is around here?
I think we just gotta go through there.
I gotta use, um...
Is there anything in the bathroom?
Besides, like...
I hope it's clean.
Please be clean.
Okay.
Um...
Let's use a chaff.
I only have nine, though.
Only stinky.
Definitely stinky.
That was close.
Ah!
Okay.
I think we got everything in here.
Actually...
Let's do that.
Let's take out...
Let's grab this.
Okay.
Okay, let's leave.
Alrighty.
Okie dokie.
Now we have to go all the way back.
So much fun.
It's my favourite part.
Love, love, love backtracking, everybody.
Backtracking my beloved.
Wait.
Is there a good way to get out?
Do I have to get through these?
It's like impossible, isn't it?
Do I have to chaff here?
Johnny is dead!
Time paradox!
It's totally possible?
Oh!
It doesn't see me as far as I thought it would.
Okay, I did it.
Easy peasy.
Oh!
I'm just gonna go, I think, through here.
Is it turned off now?
At some point it gets turned off, doesn't it?
I think it's turned off!
Yippee!
I have to go to the bathroom real quick, I think.
It's okay, it's not so bad.
Are the mines back, I wonder?
I don't remember.
Yes.
This is why we always check.
This is why we're overly cautious.
It feels like there's even more than before.
I think they put in a ton of them.
Oh my god.
There's a ton and ton of them.
It's an absolute...
minefield.
Craziness.
Well, I can just run through it.
Snake, there's a bomb planted in your items.
Harry, throw it away!
Who the hell are you?
One of them?
You'll find out soon enough.
Okay!
Oh my god!
What do you mean there's a bomb planted in my items?
Colonel!
Oh, he doesn't care.
He doesn't care.
A bomb!
Oh my god, I only have 60 seconds left on it.
Oh yeah, call master.
I didn't know before.
Let me see, if I call him after, I know there was something.
No.
Cold environments.
If you're going to use a handgun, you should equip a suppressor.
Thank you.
Okay, let's get rid of this bomb.
Wait.
Oh.
Wait, how do I get rid of it?
Wait.
Oh, there we go.
Whee!
That was a close one, Snake.
That was a close one.
Ocelot.
You'll pay for that.
That deep throat's a real enigma.
He's definitely from inside their ranks.
Is he an informer?
Oh.
Maybe some kind of renegade?
I've got the feeling there's some other force at work here.
Oh, wait, hold on.
Master.
That was too close, Snake.
It was.
Yeah.
That was quite a surprise, all right.
Hiding a bomb in your items.
That's a despicable act.
He should never...
Oh!
You'd better hurry to the underground base.
You're almost out of time.
Oh!
He should never.
Bless you.
Thank you.
What do you mean by that, Master?
He should never what?
If you go straight down the underground passageway north of the cave, you'll arrive at the communication towers.
Yeah.
You should be able to go over the glacier by using the communication tower's walkway.
Head for the towers.
Okay.
Um.
Anyway.
Mine detector.
Oh my God.
I forgot.
Okay.
Yeah.
Oh my gosh.
There're so many mines!
And then there's also the cameras.
Let's grab this.
This.
Oh.
Oh, shoot.
Uh oh.
I can't keep any more of them.
Okay.
So now I have to avoid the camera and also avoid the bombs.
This is very fun.
I like this.
Maybe I should have just taken the shortcut.
Maybe...
Let's go this way.
What the... Oh, it scared me so bad!
Oh my gosh!
That spooked me.
Like crazy.
How did you see me?
Am I okay?
Oh wait, no.
I need this.
I need the...
Wait, can I see them with the night vision?
I can't see anything with the night vision!
Look how many claymores there are.
It's so crazy.
Walks in front of camera.
How did you see me?
I thought I walked under it!
What are you talking about?
I'm looking at my little dot.
Okay.
There we go.
Let me in!
It's not so bad.
But from here, I am going to go to the bathroom real quick.
I hope you guys don't mind.
But I'm going to go to the bathroom.
Actually, I think he'll be able to see me.
So we'll crawl like that.
I'll be right back.
And I'm gonna get some more tea also.
So I'll be right back.
You guys can listen to this.
And just enjoy the music and the ambience.
BRB.
Better wash your hands.
I always do.
Okay.
Be right back.
I almost just spilled my tea.
I'm back.
Welcome
back.
Thank you.
We are no longer fishing.
Scatter!
No.
Get in here.
Welcome back.
Thank you.
What kind of tea is it?
Just some green tea?
Just some green tea.
Okay.
Okey dokey.
Alright.
This guy just left.
So perfect timing for us.
Let's go.
And I'm gonna become a box.
Wait.
I think that was the...
Was that the guy upstairs or downstairs?
I can't tell.
Oh.
Okay.
Whoo.
Now I know there's chaff grenades over there though.
So I'm gonna grab them.
Huh.
Just a box.
Why does the category say MGS2?
Oh.
It does?
That's so weird.
What sort of sword did I put in MGS1?
I'll change it.
Thanks for letting me know.
I had no idea.
Chaff grenades.
Perfect timing.
I'm
gonna wait for him to pass.
I'm scared.
This says 1 for me.
That's so weird.
I don't know.
Oh my god.
I did it again.
No.
We're going to...
We're going to basement 1.
It says MGS part 2.
As in...
It is day 2.
Yes.
That is correct.
It is the day 2.
Or the second time of me streaming.
Metal Gear Solid 2...
1.
Part 2.
Even my brain can't understand.
Even my brain can't handle it.
Yay!
Wait.
My health is good.
Life is good.
Afterlife is good.
So long.
For me it says old Metal Gear 1987 game.
What?
What is up with MewTube?
I swear, MewTube doesn't know anything, I think.
Don't attack me.
I'm just a box.
I'm just a box that you love.
Oh gosh, I can't see anything in here.
Oh, I don't need those.
Okay.
Thank you.
Love you too.
We're good.
Are the bombs here again?
Or...
I'm just gonna crawl anyway.
I can't remember.
I don't think so.
I think they're gone gone.
My immersion?
I was crawling to that part?
Ew, there's cat hair in my teeth!
What?!
Sorry, Meryl.
I'm sad about you too.
I'm more sad about my teeth.
How did I get in there?
The normal cat life.
I... I can still help.
I want to help you.
Quiet down.
Save your strength.
I was a fool.
I wanted to be a soldier.
She wanted to be a soldier, you guys.
But war is ugly.
There's nothing glamorous about it.
Snake, please save yourself.
Go on living and don't give up on people.
Don't forget me.
It's PTSD.
Snake, about Meryl.
Colonel, I'm sorry.
Listen to me.
I wasn't able to protect her.
Snake, she's a soldier.
She knows that prisoners are a part of war.
She joined up of her own free will.
I'm sure she was prepared for this.
You're very understanding now, all of a sudden.
Meryl thought she had to become a soldier.
Thought it was the only way.
She said she thought it would bring her closer to her dead father.
I love this track.
She said that?
She wasn't ready for real combat.
I shouldn't have pushed her so hard.
It's all my fault.
It's not like you, Snake.
Master!
What is it?
Sorry for eavesdropping, but I just couldn't listen anymore.
Master.
Snake, you can have regrets if you want to.
It's only natural.
But you can't keep attacking yourself for things that happened in the past.
That road leads to madness.
Believe me.
He's right.
Don't kick yourself.
It doesn't suit a legend like you.
I'm sure Meryl's just fine.
Mei Ling.
Snake, forget about Meryl.
Stop Liquid.
That's what Meryl would want too.
Meryl's still alive.
Don't talk like she's dead.
Meryl would say the same thing.
I didn't submit, okay?
Snake.
What?
Meryl.
She's pretty special to you, huh?
Don't undermine my abilities like that.
There aren't many women like her around.
That's not what I meant.
She's the Colonel's niece.
And a combat buddy.
A combat buddy?
Come on.
She's like a police interrogation.
No, I just...
I guess it's in the genes.
What do you mean by that?
What are you talking about, Colonel?
No.
I just remembered about Naomi's grandfather.
I think Naomi said he rose as high as Assistant Secretary in the FBI during Edgar Hoover's time.
Is that right?
Yes.
He was Japanese.
And he became a special undercover investigator to nab the mafia.
When was that?
Sometime in the 50s, I guess.
Where?
In New York, I think.
Naomi.
I thought you didn't have any family.
Master clocking her?
My grandfather was already dead by the time I learned about him.
I never even had the chance to meet him.
Snake.
Good luck.
Watch your back, Snake.
Suss, suss, suss.
Naomi, so suss.
I don't remember where the cameras are at.
I know it's that middle one down there, I'm pretty sure.
I don't think there's any in here.
I can hear it eventually.
That is a trap.
Ah!
Diarrhea is hereditary.
It runs in your genes.
No!
No, it doesn't, please.
Someone said to shoot the rats for a special codec.
I've never gotten that one before, but...
I don't know if I want to waste any dice as a Pam.
Have you played Unmetal?
I haven't yet, actually.
I would like to try it someday.
The crows, too?
I think I shot a crow in Twin Snakes.
The rats, though.
Shoot the rats?
Oh, there's more up there.
I'm trying to get more.
We're going to need this.
We're going to need it.
Oh, this is just PSG.
Okie dokie.
If I shoot it, if I... I know where the rats were.
I knew where they were.
Do I... How do I get them, though?
With the sniper?
I guess I'll try it once.
Don't see me.
Oh, here.
Actually, I can probably do it from here.
Let's try it.
I'm curious.
Rat.
Oh, I can't go any higher.
Uh...
Do I have to go far, far?
Ok, hold on.
I'm not going to use any dyes of him.
I'm just going to do it.
I'm a gamer.
I'm a gamer!
I shot the rat!
Who do I call?
Blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
Nastasha, I shot that rat.
Oh, need three kills.
Ok.
Blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
Oh, this was really long.
I'm so sorry.
I'm so sorry, Nastasha.
I'm sorry, Nastasha.
I'm sorry.
There's another little rat.
Oh my goodness.
The shaky cam is crazy.
Let me use the cigarettes instead so that...
It's not so bad.
I don't know if you can hear my controller.
Oh gosh.
Two!
It's giving me motion sick a little.
Oh.
Dang it.
Come here, rats.
I'll shoot you all down.
Ah!
You're so fast.
Come here, little rat.
Oh my gosh.
The shaky cam, for real.
Hello?
Snake, we don't need a rat trap.
We need someone to stop that goddamn nuke from getting launched.
Sorry, Colonel.
You seemed pretty disappointed in me, you guys.
I think he was kind of mad, for real.
I think he seemed really disappointed in me.
I'm not gonna lie.
He's angry.
In we go!
There's a lot of stuff here.
Why is the music so eerie?
This way.
I don't
remember what to do here.
Hold on.
I am?
Oh god.
Oh, here we go.
Here we go.
Oh god.
No!
Leave me alone!
Leave me alone, you freak!
You leave me alone!
Why are you so obsessed with me?
Leave me alone!
So...
Oh my gosh.
God,
am I gonna make it?
Oh my god.
I remember this...
Okay, hold on.
I do remember... I remember this part now.
But I think I'm gonna die.
I might have to redo it anyway.
That's okay, though.
I remember... I think...
I don't have a lot of stun grenades, though.
Ouch.
There we go.
Sorry, guys.
You probably were, like, screaming that in the comments.
And I forgot.
Oh, no!
Throw the grenade, Snake!
Ouch.
Okay, okay.
Hold on.
Why
are there so many of you guys?
Just keep running, Snake.
Just keep running.
And next one.
Flashbang!
That was a waste.
That's okay.
Zero.
One HP and a dream, baby.
Leave me alone!
Ration.
Climb!
I just got to the ration, too.
Even...
Okay, okay.
I don't have a lot of flash... or a lot of...
Are they...
I don't...
The reason I forgot about the stun grenades is because they don't give you any.
I only have three!
They must give you more here, right?
Or they don't.
That's fine, too.
I think one of those...
So, it's...
I think they give you more stun grenades and then they give you the rope.
You should have to avoid the other one.
I think the alert...
You have to do it, though, right?
Like...
A bunch of guys climbed up the ladder after you with MGS3?
I would cry.
Yeah, the alert is scripted.
Yeah, you have to go through this, unfortunately.
But also, I don't think it would work, the chaff, because, like, it's already...
Our thing is already jammed, so...
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay.
Um...
I'm gonna stun as much as I can, and then...
And then...
Fam...
Famas.
Start with the famas?
You think so?
Start with it, and then use the stuns later?
Mmm...
Yeah, I wonder what the speedrunning trick...
Probably just...
Just don't mess it up.
Yeah!
Oh, my God.
Okay.
Never mind.
This is so bad.
Thank you.
Flash!
Bang!
Oh...
Get up!
Snake!
Please!
The thing about the famas is I have to, like, run, you know?
I have to, like...
I have to just keep going.
So that's why it's easier to do the stun grenade.
Just flash!
Bang!
Ouch!
Get up!
Yeah.
Run!
Flash!
Bang!
Ouch!
Flash!
Oh!
Ouch!
No!
Flash!
Ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-bang!
Okay.
Now we can go to the famas.
Up.
This way.
Okay.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Ah!
Oh, my God.
Run!
Why are you so fast?
Ah!
Oh, my God.
They're all gonna come after me!
Get up!
Snake!
Snake, please.
Snake, run.
Just run, Snake!
Just run!
Ah!
So much for saving my throat.
Stop shooting at me!
Stop it!
Stop it, you freak!
You freak!
I'm gonna drink my hair.
My hair?
My cat's hair.
I'm gonna drink my tea even though it has a cat's hair in it.
Ah!
Ouch!
Are we okay?
Hmm.
Hmm-hmm.
Ugh.
There wasn't so much cat hair.
There was like two pieces.
I love my cat hair.
Yeah, I'd probably eat my cat's hair all the time.
Call it a minty.
What does that mean?
What a thrill that was.
Oh, absolutely!
I'm so cool.
You're out of shape from all that dog mushing.
Oh, look at you smiling.
Like, you could fucking do that, Colonel.
Wow!
Shut up, Colonel.
You jerk.
Master Miller!
Um, Master?
It's fine.
He's probably, like, going to the bathroom, you know?
He's fine.
Yeah, Colonel should not be talking.
Mother, ye rosebuds, while ye may.
Old time is still a-flying.
And this same flower that smiles today tomorrow will be dying.
Snake laughter is the best medicine.
You should be happy you've got enough free time to play a game.
Enjoy yourself, okay?
Thanks, Mei Ling.
Oh, wait.
I forgot Otacon.
I'm up on the roof.
That was a pretty fast climb.
I can go slowly.
But someone there forced me to move faster.
Someone?
Or like ten ones.
Well, you can relax.
Cause there's an elevator in Tower B.
Yippee!
That walkway will take you to Tower B.
And surely that will be a really easy elevator ride as well.
Surely.
How
many?
I only have one ration left.
You scared me so much.
Oh my god!
Snaaaaaaaaaaaayyyyyyyy!
Oh, oh no.
Liquid.
You're not going any far.
Die!
No!
Time for another fight.
With a hindie.
Oh well, not yet, actually.
It's a long way down.
Yeah.
If I had a rope...
You do!
I should be able to use that rope I got.
Yes.
What are you going to do?
Take on a hind with your bare hands?
Now you're mine!
If I stay here, I'm finished.
Use the rope!
Uh, I don't remember actually how I did this part.
You can't actually do that.
Here we go.
Oh my god!
Oh my god, oh my god.
Punch the chopper.
Oh gosh.
Colonel, can you help me here?
Help
me.
What do I do?
Thank you.
Okay.
Pressing right or left on the directional button.
Big jump.
You can make a big jump in that direction.
Okay.
If you press and hold the circle button while using the directional button, you can walk slowly across the wall.
If you're careful with the timing, you should be able to dodge the gunfire from behind while you rappel down.
If anyone can do it, you can, Snake.
Yeah, you want to make fun of me again?
Huh?
About... okay.
Whee!
Oh my god.
Oh, I got hit.
Oh my god, I forgot the steam too.
Ah!
Don't go into the steam, Snake.
Don't go into the steam.
Oh my god.
Ouch.
Here.
Don't get... don't get...
Uh...
Oh, ouch.
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
I'm trying to avoid stuff.
Oh my god.
Avoid the fire.
And the... and the steam.
Snake.
Please, Snake.
Snake, just go down!
Snake!
Snake, go down!
Go down.
Hit every steam and fire.
Got it.
Oh my gosh.
How did I manage that?
I don't need to know.
Oh, gosh.
Oh, that's right.
The door is frozen.
Wait.
Is this the one that I can blow up with the C2?
No.
Don't equip that.
Is this the one that I can blow up... or do I have to wait for that?
Run.
Oh.
That's not what I meant to do.
Run.
Hold on.
You guys down there, don't look at me right now.
Okay.
There we go.
Oh.
Did I...
How do I say C2?
I meant C4.
Oh, gosh.
Sorry.
I'm a little...
A little...
Shocked after all of that.
You know?
A lot just happens, everybody.
Okay?
A lot just happens.
So, again.
Oh, gosh.
Okay.
I'm going to...
I'm just looking for more rations.
Don't mind me.
C2 is called Geass.
I think you're right.
My brain got a little steamed.
I can't believe... I was... I don't even know what the hell I was doing there.
Sea floor... Floor?
Wait, sea floor?
Wait, that would also imply that there's a sea ceiling?
A sea wall?
What's wrong with me today?
Thank you!
Although star 2 was delayed around the time MGS was being developed, it would be going to effect 2000.
Star 3 however will be scrapped and replaced with SORT in 2003.
I know I'm like... Maybe this is pointless.
But I'm just gonna check anyway.
I'm a careful person, okay?
Oh, see?
There was some stuff I could grab.
There might be other stuff I can grab.
Who knows?
No turrets?
No turrets yet, you mean.
Oh wait, actually it's in the other building, isn't there?
Wait, no.
The turrets are in this building.
I don't remember.
Why am I acting like I know everything?
Oh, you're so cruel.
Such a cruel mistress.
If I... Well, I guess I shouldn't go back up there.
I don't think there was anything else up there, was there?
Let's go down to the bo... No.
It's such an annoying...
The turrets are in the elevator one?
How many?
There's even chaff grenades.
It's not so bad.
Make the level 15 mod if you want.
You gotta be strong first and then you can do this.
Why das school?
Does he know how to run?
He is Johnny T daqui.
Is that the door?
Yeah.
Okay, I'll go.
When's the out of breath codec?
We just had it!
Let's see what they say actually.
No, he's scaring me.
I need stinger missiles!
Otacon!
Yeah.
Oh.
Okay.
What are you talking about?
There's something I've got to ask you.
Well, what is it?
Well, you see, I...
I'll ask you when I see you.
Okay!
Bye!
That's a death flag.
Master!
He's got stomach issues, you guys.
He can't pick up the phone right now.
Okay.
Hmm...
I mean, if I just Nikita missile them, you think they can take a missile to the face?
Let's just snipe them.
I think that'll be easier.
I only have a three.
It just depends though.
Oh
my god.
Oh, oh, goodness.
Oh my god.
Is
this the first time I've ever seen the bullets fly?
Inga me.
I
forgot my rations.
I forgot to equip my rations.
Anyway...
I know why I said C2.
Because it was C2 of the C4s.
You get it?
Soldier got aimbots.
Yeah!
How the hell did he hit me?
From so far away.
Crazy.
Crazy, crazy.
Okay.
I'm gonna take out this guy.
Then we're gonna take out the next guy.
They should all be the same height.
Come out.
Oh, where?
Oh, yeah.
Come here.
Come on.
Lucky.
That's it, right?
Yeah.
There's...
Okay.
Yippee!
What if I didn't have the health to survive that shot?
You know?
Oh.
What if I didn't have the health for it?
Where am I?
Oh, I'm in the other tower, right?
So now...
We have to worry about the guy.
The...
Now we have to worry...
Oh!
There's the elevator.
Beep.
Huh?
Watch him, daisies.
I'm just...
I might have watched it already.
I don't maybe not remember the name.
Oh, sorry.
I instinctually go to Master Miller.
Snake, I'm heading your way.
What are you talking about?
There's something I've got to ask you.
Well, what is it?
Well, you see, I...
Oh, I'll ask you when I see you.
Bye.
Wait a minute.
Interesting.
It looks like Liquid really wants to have a showdown with you.
I'm looking at Mei-Ling's digital...
That's not even fair!
Why does he want to have a showdown in a helicopter?
I hope everyone's enjoying the live broadcast.
Sorry, Snake.
Snake, I don't like it.
Please don't go up to the roof.
I have to.
I can't run from this one.
I'm enjoying it.
Yippee!
All righty.
But...
Why am I going down?
I can't remember this part at all.
Sorry, like I said, I always forget about the Hind D fight.
Like, so I always forget what to do here.
Colonel, thanks for the super chat.
It's only going up, I think.
The Hind D...
part.
Oh!
Damn.
Time to go back up.
J-Nice.
Welcome to membership.
Thank you!
Huh?
Ah!
Don't shoot!
It's me!
It's me, Snake!
How'd you get here?
It wasn't as dramatic as your entrance, believe me.
I'm afraid of heights.
You were watching?
Yeah, I was watching.
I was riding in the back of their truck.
He was watching the whole time.
Thanks to the stealth camouflage.
The elevator, of course.
Oh, that's why I couldn't take it.
The first floor of the circular staircase was destroyed.
Yeah.
The elevator was working?
Yeah, that's right.
Okay.
You're incredible.
Like a movie hero or something.
I know.
Stop.
No.
You're wrong.
He's so obsessed with me.
In movies, the hero always saves the girl.
You mean Meryl?
Stop, Snake.
It's not your fault.
Sorry.
Forget I said anything.
Snake.
There's something I've really got to ask you.
It's why I followed you up this far.
Oh, my God.
Have you ever loved someone?
That's what you came to ask?
No.
I mean, I was wondering if even soldiers fall in love.
What are you trying to say?
I want to ask you.
Do you think love can bloom even on a battlefield?
He said it!
Thank you.
I think at any time, any place, people can fall in love with each other.
But...
if you love someone, you have to be able to protect them.
I think so, too.
I have a favor to ask.
Uh-oh.
Don't worry.
It'll be easy.
I told you before, I don't want to hurt anyone.
I don't want you to, either.
Okay.
The elevator has stopped down there.
They're so cute.
I want you to get it to move.
You see?
That's weird.
It was working before, but now it isn't.
That is weird.
Maybe the panel's broken.
Can you fix it?
It was working before.
If it's the mechanism, leave it to me.
We're leaving it to you.
I've got to go and swat a noisy fly.
Some bothersome flies.
I'll stay here and hold the fort.
Gosh, they really are brothers.
You really look like hell.
Are you okay?
Don't worry.
If I do this, it doesn't matter.
I just pretend like I'm not here.
Then I'm not scared.
Little baby.
Strange logic.
I'm counting on you.
Gosh, when he stands still, I really can't see him.
Bye-bye.
Bye-bye, Otacon.
Sweet little baby.
Okay.
Now we can go.
Oh.
I remembered.
Haha.
Oh.
Eww.
Stinger time on these?
Can I use...
I can't use the Nikita.
I only have six bullets, though.
Hmm.
I think I might just chaff it.
I think maybe each chaff I can go up two staircases, I imagine.
I have a lot more chaffs than I have Stinger.
And I'm gonna need the Stinger for the next fight.
So...
Run, run, run, run!
Run, run, run, run, run, run, run.
Oh.
Oh my god.
It didn't even have any.
Otacon Shadow Moose's Heart of Snake Champion 2005.
Oh, come on!
Go, go, go.
Beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep.
Oh.
I'm just gonna do this again.
That's fine.
This part is so goofy.
There's three of them.
...
We'll blow up the cameras as our last resort.
But I think this is better, since I have a lot of them.
I have a lot of, uh, chaff grenades and, uh...
And so, I think it's better to do it like this.
Chaff!
Oh, come on, come on snake.
Not that it matters.
Not that it matters because there won't be anymore until it's...
They literally... Oh, wait.
They literally... Why is the angle like this?
Oh, we're good!
See?
Why is it so tight?
My goodness.
We did it!
And we got more chaff grenades.
Thank you.
Perfect!
That's what she said.
Oh my god.
She said also that we got more chaff grenades?
There we go.
What a thrill.
Wrong game.
There's nothing over here, right?
Yeah.
Oh, wrong button.
The security advisor for this building takes a puff of the cigarette and on the third floor there will be three cameras.
It's true!
In Paradise Lost, Milton wrote, Solitude sometimes is best society.
And short retirement urges sweet return.
Is that why you came back, Snake?
You got tired of your short retirement in Alaska, huh?
I don't know about that.
I was forcefully... I was kidnapped, Mei Ling.
I was forcibly brought here.
They didn't give me a choice.
Liquid is still hovering around the roof of Tower B.
He's waiting for you.
Snake, it's time for you to take him on.
Take him on and take him out.
Master, do you have any wisdom for me before I fight?
No?
Okay.
Meryl, how about you?
None?
Okay.
How did Kanye work on that elevator?
You're gonna go after that hind now?
Yeah.
I can still hear the sound of its rotors.
It's just circling the tower.
Man-napped.
He must be waiting for you.
Yeah, well, you won't hear it for much longer.
Good.
In the meantime, I'll fix the elevator so you can use it later.
Thank you.
Let's hear what Nastasha has to say.
She's gonna be like, In the fifties.
You have stinger missiles.
Oh, okay.
Missiles.
Now you have a chance against the hind.
Only a chance?
Well, you are not exactly evenly armed.
That's true.
That hind is a monster.
You have only a small chance to win, but at least it's better than no chance.
No chance.
That's a pretty grim analysis, Nastasha.
To shoot down that hind, you will have to get to a place with good visibility.
Good.
Do not try to fight him in that walkway.
Get upon that roof where you will have a clean shot at him.
Okay.
All right.
I don't know how this fight's gonna go, but we shall see.
We got four rations, but our life is a little not so good.
If I think in one hit, we'll be...
Oh, wait.
We'll be dead in one hit.
But, you know.
So, the snake's finally come out of his hole.
His hole.
Are you ready now, my brother?
Why are you calling me brother?
Don't call me brother.
What the hell are you?
I'm you.
But better.
What?
Ask the father that you killed.
I'll send you to hell to feed him.
All right.
Gosh.
That was a close one.
Oh, wait.
How do I...
Wait.
Oh, my gosh.
X button?
Okay.
Oh, there are rations over here, though.
I'll save that.
I'll save those for later.
X button?
You guys, I was thinking like X.
Okay.
I'm using like a...
What's it called?
Controller.
AM.
Oh.
I can't grab him.
Come here.
Stop being so sneaky.
Face me like a man.
Oh.
Ouch.
X.
Oh.
This one.
Oh, my gosh.
He hit so hard.
Oh.
He went the wrong way.
I thought he was going to go the other way.
X.
I might need to go grab...
Oh.
How do I get up here?
Wait.
How many do I have?
Yeah.
Let's just grab these.
So we can fill up.
How
did I manage that?
I don't know.
That's crazy.
Oh.
No.
Let's go over here.
Ouch.
Actually, I'm going to go...
Oh, my gosh.
Okay.
I don't know.
He's on this side.
Oh.
I got him still.
Yipee.
Oh.
Shoot.
Don't keep shooting.
Stop shooting.
Oh, my gosh.
Unfair.
Blah...
You can't just keep shooting at me.
Uh.
Hello?
Aim.
Stinger missile?
Stinger Missile?
Hello?
Oh, okay, that's why.
He's gonna blow this thing up eventually.
Stop, stop, stop.
What?
It did such a little damage even though it was like so in his face.
What just happened?
Oh, he's doing that below.
Are we in phase two?
Hahaha.
Ouchie!
I can't... see!
Ow!
Oh my gosh, no way.
Yeah, this one's gonna...
This one's gonna... this one's gonna take a while, you guys.
Unfortunately, I think.
Or rather, a couple tries, I'd say.
I have no more rations.
I don't think there's any over here, are there?
Oi!
Ah!
That's so unfair!
How am I supposed to dodge that?
Oh my god.
She's gonna hit the walls again.
This part is so annoying.
Parry it.
Yeah, you're right.
What am I...
I have to like guess where he's gonna be at.
Hmm?
He used the sword.
So he'll probably, like, come up around... around over here, right?
He's gone.
Ah!
Oh!
Oh gosh.
Yeah, I don't think this is... I don't think this is the... this is not the run, but that's okay!
Ah!
Can the box counter the Heinz missiles?
My box?
Like, my cardboard box?
Ah!
It's okay.
Like I said, I knew this one would be...
Still annoying, though.
Oh, whoops.
There we go.
Still annoying, though!
So, the snakes finally come out of this hole!
How did I dodge that?
Are you frustrated, brother?
Which way is he going?
This way?
Thought
he was gonna go the other way.
Okay.
Goodness gracious.
Whoa!
How fast do I need to be...
with the second phase?
This part.
Oh gosh, here it comes.
Yeah!
How fast do I need to be when he comes up is my thing.
You know?
No body armor?
I don't have any.
I don't have any bo... I never picked it up.
I don't even remember where it's at.
It's okay.
Oh, wait, he's here.
Oh, this is that way.
Ah!
Oh
my gosh.
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
So, shoot once he comes up, but after he shoots.
Oh, come on.
That's so unfair.
Yeah, boo-boo!
Okay.
So, like, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Oh, I wasn't fast enough.
Oh, my God.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, sir.
Sir, sir, sir.
Please, please.
Oh, there we go.
Oh, I'm not fast enough.
I don't think.
Wait, how many?
I have 10.
Let's grab this while we're here.
This is so unfair.
No!
Oh, my God.
Stop, stop, stop, stop, stop.
Snake.
You scared me sometimes, Snake.
You scare me sometimes, man.
You scare me alot.
Oh, my God.
Okay, okay, okay.
And he's back below.
He's...
I hate when he's over there.
It's really hard to shoot him from there.
Nice and nice of...
Ha ha ha ha!
Slow and steady I suppose.
A little pause.
What was that?
Like
I shot him, but I didn't.
He's just yelling.
He's just yelling into the void.
Liquid, you're so silly.
Silly guy.
He's gonna come up any second now.
No?
Okay.
Just kidding.
Wait, where did he go?
Oh, shoot.
Nice.
Using that radar.
Oh my gosh, that was fast.
That's me fighting you, bozo.
That was my bad.
I instinctually pressed it.
I knew I shouldn't have though.
Oh my goodness.
Come on, come on out.
I wonder what the speedrun strat for this is.
Because there's no way that you're just supposed to stand here and wait for him, right?
That feels crazy.
Did they skip it?
Strat has to punch the chopper.
Obviously.
You can shoot him from the edge of the rails.
You can?
I'm too afraid of it blowing up in my face though, so I will not do that.
I'm too afraid of it literally exploding on top of me.
Knowing me, I'll miss somehow, you know?
That's just how it is.
Minto gaming.
Oh, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
I did not mean to get hit there.
Can I hit you now?
Can I get you now?
Dang it.
I missed my chance.
Well, that's frustrating.
Run,
run, run, run.
Don't miss your chance.
Mr. FonTown.
Oh, why did I...
I, I, I, I...
How many missiles?
Okay, I only have six.
Oh gosh, oh gosh, oh gosh.
I'm starting to throw.
I'm starting to throw, you guys.
Oh my gosh.
Do I have enough to beat him?
More missiles will spawn, right?
Oh, if I can't beat him with the...
these, I'll have to use like Nikita or something.
Wouldn't that be something?
Let's get more quick.
I only have five left.
Then I'll have six.
You'll get more once you run out?
Okay.
He went back under too fast.
I was too slow.
Skill issue.
Something, something.
Ew,
for being such a coward.
You're the one in the helicopter.
Why do you keep having to go under?
Huh?
Why do you keep hiding yourself?
Where are you?
Oh, there you are!
Wait a second.
Wait, do I need one more?
Oh, his, his, his propellers are really slow.
Yippee!
It's exploding, Liquid!
It's on fire!
Wow, he's so cool.
He's just like an action hero.
Otacon's watching from the door.
He's like peeking from the door.
He's like, wow.
That takes care of the cremation.
What a loser.
Oh, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Yay!
The behind the...
Snake, the elevator's working.
Yay!
Fixed it?
No, that's the weird thing.
Oh.
It just moved by itself.
Okay.
It's headed your way now.
Is that so?
Okay.
That explosion before, what was it?
Oh, I had to take out that helicopter.
Helicopter?
That's incredible, Snake.
No, it's not.
That's nothing.
I just want to make sure again.
This is the way to get to where Metal Gear is being stored?
Yeah.
The entrance to the underground maintenance base is towards the back of the snow field ahead.
Okay.
Find a safe place to hide out for a while.
I'm going under power.
I just want to say your arigatou, arigatou too is the absolute cutest thing ever.
Might be the best alert stream of all time.
You think so?
Tell me if you need to.
Thanks.
I mean, arigatou, arigatou too.
I should make some new ones.
Those are old ones.
I should make some new ones, right?
Okay.
Nice.
We did it.
It only took two tries.
It only took two tries, and we have three rations left.
And Otacon said I'm incredible.
So.
So, I believe in, you know, Psycho Mantis.
He said that I was a gamer.
So, he said I was a gamer.
I do wonder what I'll get this time.
Probably, I think before I got Elephant, I'll probably get Elephant again.
If I had to guess.
If I had to guess, I'll probably get it again.
Wait, where do I go?
I just go downstairs?
Why is it in Japanese?
Because I'm playing Integral.
So, yeah.
It's all worth it to hear Otacon compliment you.
I know that's what I'm saying.
Do I have to use my chaffs again?
I guess we'll get our answer in a second.
Oh, yes I do.
Or I could use my Stinger Missiles because...
But it only shoots... look at both.
Yay!
I only have one ammo left.
It'll show me the camera.
Splash damage.
Nikita.
I think from here, Nikita would be okay.
In fact...
I mean, I know I'll get Stinger Missile ammo later on again, but...
Oh, I can't use the Nikita.
Oh, I think because the radar doesn't work, right?
It's all blocked, so...
I'll just chaff.
I got more.
Wait!
Oh,
dang it.
So close.
Wait!
I think that's the last one because it's only one, right?
Yes, that's the last one.
I guess we could have shot that one, actually.
Oh!
Aww, Arakan!
You left me a bunch of presents!
How did you know that bullets were my favorite food?
Um, okay.
Let's... call?
I don't know why, but the elevator just started working again.
If you take it all the way to the bottom of Tower B and go outside, you'll be in the snowfield.
Yes.
The entrance to the underground maintenance base is in the north of the snowfield.
Oh, she sounds a little... Why do you sound a little nervous about that?
You did it, Snake!
You shot down the hind!
I'm so worried!
One stinger missile is worth, like, 200k USD and you just have to destroy Walmart now.
But even so, just because we've taken out their leader doesn't mean they're going to give up.
They're still going to try to launch that nuke.
You're right.
There's no time to waste.
Hurry!
The underground base is past the communications tower.
The elevator's working again, isn't it?
Yeah?
Oh...
Master?
No response.
Nastasha?
I know!
Easy.
I'm not just one man.
I'm... a superman.
Not copyright.
Yeah, I'm so great.
I'm, like, kind of awesome.
Oh.
Okay.
Let's go in here.
I'm going to equip my gun just in case.
I don't think anything's going to happen.
I'm just, you know...
I just, you know...
Huh?
Body armor is in the blast furnace.
Wait, it's where?
Because I do want it, eventually.
It's in the blast furnace or back of the gas-filled rooms.
Oh!
Okay, okay, okay.
Cool.
I will go back there.
Huh?
Otacon, you said it was working.
I don't know why, but the elevator...
No, it's not!
It's not working!
Oh!
It's working!
Just kidding.
I lied.
I'm a liar.
Yes?
Snake, there's something I forgot to tell you before.
What's that?
What?
There were five stealth camouflage prototypes in my lab.
And one of them should have been mine.
Yeah?
So, if you take out the one I'm wearing, that leaves four.
Hey, this isn't first grade math class.
Uh-huh.
I thought I'd get one for you.
So, I went back to the lab.
And...
Spit it out already!
The four suits were missing.
Uh-huh.
Also, about the elevator that I checked out.
It's really strange.
It was like someone was intentionally holding it.
When you were riding on it, did the weight limit warning go off?
That's another thing that bothered me about it.
Look how oomph it!
The warning went off, and I know I couldn't be over the limit.
How much do you weigh?
About 135.
Skinny legend!
But that elevator had a weight limit of 650 pounds.
It would take it to the next level.
The elevator was full of people!
Like, at least five people.
Five people!
Look out, Snake!
The guys who stole my stealth prototypes are in there with you!
Oh my god!
Oh, wait.
Hold on.
There we go.
Oh, ouchie ouchie.
Who's hitting me?
Oh my god.
Oh, there we go.
One of them gave me a ration.
Nice.
Oh.
Are you... oh, still?
Still alive?
How are you still alive?
Are
you dead now?
Finally.
Oh, chokehold's better.
You know, it's fine.
Then I got all these bullets.
I gotta use them.
I only used, like, half.
Then we got a free ration out of it.
Well, that was exciting, wasn't it?
More chaff, more chaff, more chaff.
Why does it feel like if this was MGS3, there would be a little frog in there for me to shoot?
You know what I mean.
Oh.
Another ration.
Itadakimasu.
Nice.
Yeah, a little keroutan.
Okay.
I almost just died.
I almost just died for real.
Oh, no.
Holy cow.
This is so unfair.
Oh, you scared the shit out of me.
I'm sorry.
If only we can aim like twin snakes.
I know, right?
I wish.
Okay, I chaff.
I wonder why they're giving me so much sniper ammo.
Oh!
Run, run, run, run, snake!
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, snake, go, snake, go, snake, go, snake!
Oh God!
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Wait, oh my God, there's more!
Just go, just go.
We're fine.
Hehehe.
Woah, it's pitch darkness.
Can I see anything if I use the sniper?
Oh, I can.
That's actually pretty cool.
I don't remember if I Nikita Missiled this last time or if I properly did the fight, but...
I might just Nikita Missile.
I don't know.
We'll see.
We might do a mix of both.
Who knows.
Codec 140.66
Yay, music channel!
We got the other one in the first stream.
Thank you guys for telling me about these.
They're so cool.
Nice.
Okay.
It looks like the weather is getting worse.
Try using your binoculars.
Oh yeah!
What about the satellite data?
I'm sorry, Snake.
I can't see the entrance in the satellite photos either.
What about a heat source?
An exhaust pipe or something?
I can't confirm anything.
Only that there are multiple heat sources to the southeast of your position.
That's probably just the burning wreckage from the Hind.
Snake, you're in a big open space surrounded by water.
The entrance to the underground base should be somewhere in there.
Somewhere in there.
Stay close to the walls and you won't get lost.
Okay.
Snake, you're our only hope.
Please stop them from launching that nuke.
Okay.
Snake just stares at the music.
I know it's so funny.
Otacon, which direction is the underground base?
It's in the snowfield to the north of Tower B.
The door is security level six.
Six.
The weather's terrible.
Make sure you don't get lost out there.
Snake?
I hear dogs.
I don't have to tell you, but it's bitter cold out there.
It'd be dangerous to stay out in the snowfield too long.
He's back!
Master!
You've recovered from your RBS!
It may look pretty at first, but it'll severely limit your visibility.
Master's back!
Be careful.
I'll be right back.
All right.
Let's get this over with.
But also, is there anything around here?
I went through a couple of reactions, so...
Lucky me!
Snake, are you okay?
I'm fine.
Otacon, were there any other stealth prototypes?
No, there were only five.
So, this isn't stealth camouflage, then?
Sniper.
What are you talking about?
Someone's aiming at me.
In the middle of this blizzard.
It's her!
Wolf?
Sniper Wolf?
Yes, it's her.
It's definitely her.
Otacon, you sound like you're happy.
He's smiling.
He's cheesing.
No, I'm not.
So, then what is it?
Oh, his glasses.
Snake, please don't kill her.
Are you insane?
Please!
She's a good person.
Master, we're back after a funny first life, not the toilet.
Listen to me, kid.
I'm going to get you out of here.
She's a merciless killer.
I can see you perfectly from up here.
She's so hot.
Look at her.
I told you, I never quit the hunt.
Now you're mine.
Wolf, no, you can't.
She's got that vocal fry.
Don't get between a wolf and his prey.
You're pretty good if you can hit me in this storm.
You see, women naturally make better soldiers.
Wolf, don't do this.
Snake, I'm near.
I'm near.
Why is her vocal fry so sexy, though?
Is that right?
Well, I'm going to send you a love letter, my dear.
Do you know what that is?
It's a bullet straight from my gun to your heart.
Please, Wolf.
Snake, no.
Quiet.
Snake.
Don't get in our way.
Snake, no.
Now I'm going to pay you back for Meryl.
Meryl.
You men are so weak.
You're weak.
You could never finish what you start.
That's what I'm about to do.
That's literally what I just said I was going to do.
Okay.
Run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run.
Run, run, run.
Oh, gosh.
Okay.
There's, like, this truck up here.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, my God.
This maybe is a bad idea.
Oh.
Okay.
Never mind.
Anyway.
Let's just leave.
Oh, my God.
Let's just leave over here and get down.
If I just...
Okay.
First, I'm going to find her.
I'm going to find her.
Where is she at?
Where are you at, girl?
Oh, there you are.
Okay.
That
one doesn't count, you guys.
That one doesn't count.
That doesn't count.
That's so silly.
Oh my goodness gracious.
That one doesn't count.
I don't actually remember how I did this before.
I think I hid behind...
here or something.
It even looks different, which is so cool.
Depending on where I'm at.
That's so awesome!
I'm going to hit all of this.
I can see you where you are.
I'm near.
Oh shoot, man!
I mean, don't shoot, man!
I never even got...
Wait, did this spawn a new ration?
Yippee!
Okay, alright.
I'm going to shoot Nikita.
What if I shoot it from here?
Can I not shoot it?
Oh.
Is that her?
Yep.
Okay, I have to find a way.
Explode into me!
Oh, because I un-equipped it.
Let's find a way around.
Maybe...
Wait, so she can't hit me.
Oh, there is no way around.
Interesting.
Okay, but she can't hit me while this is going.
So...
If I just get up here...
Ouch.
If I even can.
Oh my god.
Oh god.
Don't hit me.
You can go uphill if you've got speed.
I
don't know why the sniper missions are giving me so much trouble when literally, those were the easiest for me before.
I can't even climb...
crawl up this.
Run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run.
But I gotta be, like, super speed.
I gotta be, like, the speediest ever.
Snake, come on.
I don't think I have a lot of dizisapan.
Yeah, I don't have a lot.
Uh-oh.
Gosh.
I don't even know where to go.
This is such a terrible location.
I don't even...
Oh.
Stinger her.
It won't let you.
It even says...
Ha!
Cigarettes?
They don't work as well, though.
They work, but they don't work as well.
Hmm.
Maybe I just, like, stick around back here and kinda...
Oh, no.
Can't see anything from back here.
Oh, a little bit.
A little bit.
Actually, a lot of it.
I might be able to do it from over here.
If I run it.
Or if I...
How fast do I have to be?
Then Akira can go up from the sides.
I can?
I don't believe you.
From the right little mountain?
These?
Like, this?
Like, if I shoot it right here, it'll go up.
The mountain.
Try it out.
You know what?
I will try.
Sorry.
I accidentally unequipped it.
I've been having that problem all day where I keep pressing R1 to view in first person instead of triangle.
Okay.
I won't unequip it.
Oh.
Shit.
Not that way.
What are you...
Wait.
What are we talking about then?
Okay.
Hold on.
Oh.
It went over.
Okay.
We can do it from here.
It worked.
Oh.
Can I get it right now?
Wait.
She's waiting for me.
You bitch.
She's a monster.
How did she live?
Well, I just wasted one, but we can maybe get her with the amount.
Actually, I think I can start the cutscene.
There we go.
Snake, are you okay?
I'm not okay, actually.
I'm really scared at how she...
she didn't die to that.
I'm actually quite scared.
Okay.
Sorry.
This is an annoying one to skip, isn't it?
I think I, like, literally first tried her last time.
So, another thought.
Okay.
Oh.
Shit.
There
we go.
Nice.
Enemy.
That's so cute.
You don't see it coming, do you?
She's running.
You!
Ah, you!
She got me, you guys.
Oh, I can use the stinger.
I don't know why I wouldn't...
Go
up the side.
Go up the side.
Adjust.
Oh, this is so... this is so... no.
You guys, this is not... this is not gonna work.
This is not gonna work for me.
Oh, man.
Where is she?
Where is she at?
Where are you?
Please!
You're gonna waste my medicine.
Where?
Where the hell?
Sniper wolf, stop being a coward!
What the?
Oh.
Oh my god.
I can't move.
I saw her aiming at me, though.
From where?
Maybe she's over...
Hello?
Wouldn't you move if you can't see me?
Oh my god.
I'm so shaky.
I'm nervous.
Oh!
Ah!
I know!
I wasted my whole disappearance!
Because of you.
Get her!
Get her face!
I'm gonna get her arm.
Okay, that doesn't work.
Sure.
Sniper wolf.
Oh my god.
Finally!
Good lord.
Wasting so much...
Wasting so much ammo.
Cigarettes, please.
Save me.
Oh no, wait.
What if I get hit again?
I'll die.
Oh gosh.
Okay, hold on.
This is not good.
Stop!
Stop running!
There we go.
I can still hit her.
I'm just a little shaky.
I'm just a little rusty, you guys.
I'm just a little... I'm looking...
I'm looking directly at a beautiful woman.
Of course I would be so...
I would be so nervous.
Of course.
Not even a Dezipam can help me.
Here, you guys, I'm...
I'm... I'm...
Yeah, that's right.
I'm... I'm hopeless.
I'm hopeless.
I'm just a...
I'm just a snake in love.
Snakes don't even have hands, so, you know what?
Give me credit.
Just screw these, okay?
Oh!
Oh, I almost got her.
I only have three bullets left and then I'm gonna have to run and grab more.
Come on, wolf!
Come here!
I mean...
Wolf!
Wolfy wolf!
Yeah!
I'm a-gaming!
I'm gaming!
Oh god.
We're gaming without the Dezipam!
Oh, sheesh.
Oh my god.
Okay.
I think it's time for me to...
run.
We'll go back to that spot in a second after I grab some ammo.
Ammo!
Oh!
Okay.
Only five.
That's fine.
I don't mind.
I think there was some more up here.
Yep.
Okay.
Thank you.
I'm back in position now.
Okay.
Where'd you go?
Where'd you go, pretty lady?
Don't shoot at me.
Okay.
Oh, shoot.
No, no.
Controller this way.
Oh, gosh.
You know what?
I'm gonna use the rations and then I'm gonna go to the cigarettes.
There we go.
Okay.
Come here.
Come here, pretty lady.
I'm kind of a genius.
Oh, gosh.
The cigarettes don't help very much, you guys.
So close.
Oh my god.
They don't help very much at all.
Anybody who says that they help so much is a liar.
Oh, I was right in position.
Please.
I got...
Look at me and my smokes.
Prevail in the rematch against Sniperwolf.
Yippee.
No, the first one didn't count, you guys.
The first one didn't count.
I don't remember even...
Oh, how did I die?
I don't even remember.
Oh, we go straight to her.
Cutscene time.
I wanna explore a little.
Oh, no.
I'm gonna be so sad.
Concentrating.
I am longshot.
You cannot save me.
I did that.
Gosh.
I'm sorry.
Please.
Just finish me quick.
I am a Gurd.
I have always dreamed of a peaceful place like this.
This is a nice place to die.
A Gurd.
That's why you're called Wolf.
I was born on a battlefield.
Raised on a battlefield.
I saw gunfire, sirens, and screams.
They were my lullabies.
Hunted like dogs, day after day.
Driven from our ragged shelters.
That was my life.
Each morning I'd wake up and find a few more of my family or friends still beside me.
I'd stare at the morning sun and pray to make it through the day.
The governments of the world turned a blind eye to our misery.
But then he appeared.
Big Boss.
My hero.
Saladin.
He took me away from all that.
Saladin?
You mean Big Boss?
I became a sniper.
Hidden.
Saladman.
Watching everything through a rifle scope.
Now I could see war.
Not from the inside, but from the outside.
As an observer, I watched the brutality.
Caesar Saladin.
The stupidity.
Stop.
Stop ruining the scene.
Of mankind through the scope of my rifle.
I joined this group of revolutionaries.
To take my revenge on the world.
But...
I have shamed myself and my people.
Big Boss really likes snipers, doesn't he?
I am no longer the wolf I was born to be.
In the name of vengeance, I sought my body and my soul.
Wolves are noble animals.
They're not like dogs.
On Yupik, the word for wolf is keglynek.
The Aleuts revere them as honorable cousins.
They call mercenaries like us dogs of war.
It's true.
We're all for sale at some price or another.
But you're different.
Untamed.
Solitary.
You're no dog.
You're a wolf.
Who are you?
He takes such like...
He's so compassionate, even for the other team, you know?
You spared Meryl's life.
She...
She was never my real target.
I don't kill for sport.
Rest easy.
You'll die as the proud wolf you are.
I finally understand.
I wasn't waiting to kill people.
I was waiting for someone to kill me.
A man like you.
You're a hero.
Please, set me free.
I love you.
What is it?
My gun.
Give it to me.
Don't trip.
She's part of me.
Everyone's here now.
It's probably best that she doesn't care about Otakon, you know?
Just...
Just be more painful for him.
Set me free.
No!
Snake.
Think.
You said that love could bloom on the battlefield.
But I couldn't save her.
What are you doing?
No.
We're turning it to its owner.
I don't need a handkerchief.
Why?
I don't have any more tears to shed.
I'm going to the underground base.
We're out of time.
I know.
You'll have to protect yourself now.
Don't trust anyone.
If I can't stop Metal Gear, this whole place will probably be bombed to hell.
Yeah.
We might not meet again.
I'll hang on to my codec.
I want to keep helping.
You can leave anytime.
Get a head start.
A head start on your new life.
How is he supposed to leave?
This part is so good.
Snake!
What was she fighting for?
What am I fighting for?
What are you fighting for?
If we make it through this, I'll tell you.
I'll tell you.
Okay.
I'll be searching too.
You have to ruin it.
All the cards are just stupid.
Okay.
That scene gets me every time, you guys.
Man.
It's so bad.
If I say I was reminded of the barking noises every time everyone...
Wait.
Barking noises everyone made at Off-Clyde when hearing the wolves howl.
Shut up!
No!
Okay.
I have no more tears to shed.
I'm just like Snake.
I'm not crying.
I'm fine.
You're crying.
Wait.
What is it?
Oh.
Seven.
Oh gosh.
She scared me.
It's kind of like...
It's...
I think with her face covered, it's even scarier.
You know?
How many tissues did it take?
So...
Only that angle right there?
This one?
I like that we can't see Snake's face though.
A little dramatic, you know?
Yeah.
Aye!
Yep.
I...
I remember you.
Okay.
Hold on.
Oh.
I need to have my key.
To open it.
Okay.
Slip inside.
Oh wait.
It doesn't matter.
I'm crouched.
Yeah.
Oh no.
More disabowm.
Stun grenade.
And ration.
Oh look.
You can see them.
That's so cool.
I never noticed you were able to...
Oh gosh.
Snake out.
I thought...
Wait.
I thought I wasn't full.
I just looked.
Oh wait.
Those are the claymores.
I was looking at the C4.
My bad.
Okay.
I can't trust anything.
Lots of bullets.
We have these old graphics in the room.
Where do we see...
Behind D?
Oop.
What's in there though?
Go to the bottom one?
Okay.
Bottom corner.
Oh!
There's a ration.
Do I go up here?
Oh.
Can I see it from...
Oh my god.
Snake.
Just climb.
Like from here?
Yeah.
I'm checking.
Press against the wall?
With the tree in view.
This tree?
It's so specific, right?
Ah!
There it is!
Huh?
Colonel, listen to me.
I found a parachute near the wreckage of the Hind.
Dun dun!
A parachute?
You don't think that Liquid survived?
Impossible.
As soon as he jumped out of the pilot's seat, he'd be sliced up faster than an onion on an infomercial.
That's true.
That is true.
So what's that parachute doing there then?
I have no idea.
A trap.
Either that, or a message.
To me.
Meaning I'm not dead, I suppose.
Scary.
Maybe.
But I think it's more like, I'll string you up.
Well, in any case, don't let your car down.
Naomi had nothing to say about that.
I won't.
Naomi was just like, no comment, Snake.
Why did you say it like that?
No comment.
Okay.
Nothing
here.
Nothing here.
Is this a fast travel truck?
Okay, before we go in here, there's the one with the camera room.
I think this is also a camera room.
Yep.
What's in here though?
What are those?
I can't tell...
Oh gosh, I still don't know what type of bullet stuff is.
Okay, there's like a slight window of opportunity.
Oh my gosh.
Don't scare me like that.
Oh, Nikita.
Nikita missile.
Oh, I should probably have mine, just in case.
It's so quiet.
Wait, but before it looked out...
the room, you see that?
Like... it like...
had the whole thing open.
Oh, there we go.
Oh my gosh.
We're fine.
I didn't go in here, right?
Oh!
This is where we're supposed to go.
Then what was this one down here?
Is this one we...
can go into?
Rations...
and... something.
I'm just gonna chat.
I give up.
I don't care what rank I get.
Oh, wait.
So, it's okay.
You don't have to keep commenting.
She's gonna get blah blah blah rank.
It's totally fine.
I don't really care.
I don't care about stuff like that.
But thanks for your concern.
We got the next box!
And this one.
Oh, nope.
Chaffs!
Chaff!
Grenade!
Okay, we got it all.
Let's get the heck out of here.
Okay, now we can go though.
Beep!
We care a lot.
Well, then you can discuss it amongst yourselves.
Not in my chat!
Here we go.
Oh, yeah.
Chaff.
Oh.
Toxic streamer.
Disc 2!
Oh!
Wow!
Press the 3 thingy.
Oh.
I'm checking right now.
Okay.
That was all Disc 1?
Yeah.
But Disc 2 is shorter, you know.
I wish I could headshot people.
Okay.
From here, I gotta go down.
I wonder if I can knock and get him over.
Here.
I wonder if I can choke him.
Come here.
Oh my god.
Oh, thanks.
I don't need that though.
Okay.
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna save real quick.
And...
In China, they say it's better to live ugly than to die beautiful.
I think it's true.
Once you're dead, you'll never have another chance to be happy.
I can't understand people who want to die before their time.
Please, Snake, promise me that you'll come back alive.
Aww.
I promise.
I promise, you girly.
Where is the body armor?
Oh.
Nothing?
Yikes.
Alright, Campbell.
Snake, that's a blast furnace.
I'm already dead though, so what am I supposed to do?
What do they use that for?
There's no airport on the base, so it's hard to bring in supplies.
They must have built a blast furnace so they could make building materials and such.
That makes sense.
I'm starting to sweat.
It's getting kind of warm.
My OG MGS1 disk was damaged by an earthquake.
Oh no!
Insurance covered by the replacement?
That's so awesome.
Wait, what did he say?
Tried to find what?
Uh oh.
Master, you and I, we're nothing more than dogs, are we?
That's not like you, Snake.
Don't let what Sniper Wolf said bother you.
Listen, there's not a soldier alive that doesn't question himself.
And if there is one, he's nothing more than a murderer.
But someone like Wolf, a soldier who's looking for nothing more than their own death, is no good to anyone either.
Once she started to look for death, it was all over.
That's how you'll end up too, Snake.
Whoa.
There's a cargo elevator in the northeast part of the bottom floor.
I know!
You can take that to Metal Gear's underground base.
You'll spot it right away.
It's got a big patrol light attached to it.
Okay!
Thanks, Otacon!
Oh, wait, no, that's not what I meant to do, Nastasha.
What's up, Snake?
Do not say... Talk to you later, Snake!
Talk to you later!
You have a good view, though your movement is limited.
It might be a good place to take out your enemy with your PSG-1.
Won't that be too loud?
Or is it because it's so loud in here that it would be fine to take them out?
Wait, is she a genius?
Wait, is she serious?
Wouldn't it be too loud, though?
Seriously?
Where are all the guys, though?
Okay, there's a camera there.
Oh my god.
It's like...
Nastasha, I can't see anything.
Nastasha.
Okay, there's two cameras.
I know there's guys on the other side, though.
Let's just get out.
Huh?
What was that noise?
Can I even see them from here?
Nastasha?
I don't know what you're talking about, girl.
I hope you like my advice.
After this mission, you'll never hear from me again.
It's true!
She writes her book in dips.
Huh?
What was that noise?
Wait, maybe from over here.
Maybe from here.
Nastasha, girl, what?
Are we playing the same game?
Where do you want me to shoot these guys from?
What?
I'm eating floor right now.
Nastasha, please.
Okay, whatever.
I thought she was cooking.
I really thought.
Okay.
This guy right here.
Where are they anyway?
I don't even see the other guys here.
Actually, now that I think about it.
There's a guy walking around over there, isn't there?
Look at the little rats.
Does she mean the cameras?
Everyone's allowed to give a little bad advice as a treat.
Okay, I'm nervous about this one.
Oh, there he is!
There he is!
I thought there were three guys, though.
Okay, I'm nervous about this because, you know, sometimes the wall and I don't really get along.
Oh, God.
Sometimes the wall and I don't really get along.
Oh, my God.
There he is.
He doesn't show up on my radar, which is...
Oh, yes, he does.
Just kidding.
Is this where I should...
Yes.
Yippee!
Maybe I can do it from here.
I just want to know what her thought process is, truly.
Maybe from here I can do it.
Nastasha!
Nastasha, there's no way!
From the staircase?
Sorry.
I know I keep trying this.
I'm just...
I can't even... I can't even...
I can't even reach him.
Oh, my God.
He doesn't come up the stairs, does he?
Does he even look up the stairs?
I don't know where he... Oh, there he is.
I need to be on the stairs.
He's gonna see me, though.
He's gonna see me in my box.
He's about to see me in my box.
He's gonna go, huh?
Just a box.
See?
Oh,
God.
Don't see me.
Don't come this way.
C4.
If he comes this way, we're taking him out.
Is he okay?
What is he doing?
Are you okay, buddy?
Did you get a little spooked by something?
We have to go inside this elevator to...
Sorry, hold on.
I'm just getting my bearings.
To... for later.
I believe.
Is he good?
What is happening?
What's wrong with you?
Oh, shit.
I was gonna go for it.
But he...
He came back.
Don't come this way.
What is he doing?
We'll just leave him to his devices.
He's got demons.
He's dealing with something, you guys.
I don't know what to tell you.
He's going through it a little bit.
Or something.
Here comes the elevator.
Here it comes.
They're giving me lots of bullets.
I sure hope that this elevator will be...
a calm, nice, collected little ride.
Surely this one will be the calm elevator ride.
Oh, the body armor!
Should I get it now or later?
Where is it at?
Because I have to come back here.
I think I could...
Well, I'll want it before...
Vulcan Raven.
Probably.
You can get it now.
Get it now.
Where is it at?
Can you guys backseat for me?
Huh?
Got a vent?
Inside that vent.
That's a vent.
There's a vent.
Is there a vent here?
Am I crazy?
There's no vent in this.
Oh my goodness.
In here?
Oh.
Ouch!
I forgot.
Is that it?
I believe they mean the door.
Yeah, this is not really a vent, you guys.
PSG.
Unless there's a vent inside here.
Is that it?
That looks like more bullets.
In
here?
Somewhere.
Somewhere around here, perhaps?
Ouch!
Oh?
There's stuff to crawl under?
Okay, hold on.
I'll go back.
Wait, under...
There's a marked entrance on the radar.
When he came in.
Crawl under the pipes on the left side of the room.
Okay, thanks, mod!
Ouch!
Okay.
Wait.
Crawl under the pipes on the left side of the room.
Not the ghost ration, right?
Stun grenade.
Take that.
Wait.
Oh!
Okay, inside here.
I see it!
Oh, my God.
Sorry, I'm a little slow.
Again.
There we go.
Here!
I see it.
Oh...
Okay,
hold on.
I gotta scoot out a little bit to stand up.
And...
Thrill.
Bunny armor!
Anything else around here?
Ooh, that's a stove, actually.
More chopper in it, I'll take it.
Okay.
Beep beep!
There we go.
Nice.
Okay, thanks guys!
Sorry.
A little slow.
Oh!
How did I?
Oh my god!
It's always this one!
It's faster than I anticipate it being, which is why it gets me every time.
But we're fine.
We're okay.
We're heading back.
We're leaving.
We don't care about those guys.
Okay.
Thank you guys.
Thank you, thank you.
Okey dokey!
What else is around here?
Anything else?
Don't think so.
Oh!
Just kidding.
Can I fall here?
Can I fall and die?
That would really be unfortunate, wouldn't it?
No more SOCOM.
SOCOM.
Get outta here, orb!
Actually, thanks for being here and doing your job.
That I totally pay you.
To do.
Okey dokey!
Let's go.
Beep!
Beep, beep, beep.
Beep.
Maybe a card?
Card six.
There we go.
Oh my god!
No!
This was supposed to be a peaceful elevator ride!
Dun, dun, dun, dun, dun.
Actually, um, actually...
I'm sorry.
How did you live my choke?
How did you live...
How did you...
How did you survive?
Scripted!
It's so scripted!
Oh my god.
Ouchie ouch.
Please.
Please let me get up.
Oh my god.
I'm trying to shoot it!
I'm just holding down.
This is... This is ridiculous.
This is ridiculousness.
Oh!
They live... They die.
I live.
Skill issue something something.
I hear them.
Ah!
Aren't there also...
Um...
Oh, wait.
It won't let me use the mine detector.
But aren't there also mines in there?
I think so.
Oi!
Just avoid them.
Um... um... card.
Beep!
Okay, this is the calm one.
Unless... I wanna have a little fun.
Unless I'm a little bit of a freak.
Actually, I can't see anything.
Can I even snipe them?
You know what?
It's fine.
It's probably for the best.
Brr... brr...
Brr... brr... brr... brr... brr... bird... bird...
I punched the bird!
I punched the bird, you guys!
Oh.
Yeah?
Sorry, Master Miller.
I punched a bird.
Oh.
Okay.
Not about the bird.
Yes.
Okay.
Yeah?
Why are you so rude to your master?
What are you saying?
Yeah, yeah.
What?
Oh!
Why would he have...
They first started in 1960.
In Chicago.
Not New York.
Dun dun dun!
You better check it out.
The chief and the president mysteriously dying.
And that ninja.
Too many strange things are happening.
There are a lot of strange things happening.
Are you saying that Naomi might be behind it?
I don't know.
Either that, or she's working with the terrorists.
Could it be?
If I find out anything, I'll call.
In the meantime, be careful.
Master, I'm scared.
I can't trust anybody.
Wait, let's, uh...
Oh.
Oh, I wanted to punch that bird.
Dang it.
Ooh, it's chilly here.
It's really blue.
Campbell?
Colonel, where's Naomi?
I'm right here, Snake.
What is it?
Oh, nothing.
I wasn't asking.
I wasn't... I wasn't asking for it.
By now, those terrorists have finished their launch preparations.
Stop wasting time.
Metal Gear's base is up ahead.
Snake, it's over 30 below outside.
What's wrong?
Nothing.
Snake,
don't be so obvious.
Snake, come on.
Stop lollygagging around.
Snake, stop being so obvious.
Master Miller, I'm scared.
I want to ask you about Naomi.
Yeah.
I'm looking into the details now.
But it doesn't look good.
Weren't you ever suspicious about her, Snake?
A lot.
I was a lot, yeah.
Snake, keep your guard up.
Master!
Master, you're the only one I can trust!
What the hell are all these crows doing around here?
Crows?
You got me?
There were crows around from before.
But for some reason, they started to really increase in number around the same time that Foxhound came to the base.
Creepy.
It's really weird.
I wonder what it could mean.
Did that just say rally weird?
Did I... Did I...
It's rally weird.
Stasha, bring us off topic.
As long as the strategy of nuclear deterrence continues, nuclear weapons may be reduced, but they will never be eliminated.
If you think about it, nuclear reduction does not mean much without elimination.
There she goes.
I figured the only way to achieve nuclear elimination was to work from the inside to convince them of the ineffectiveness of the deterrence theory.
Seems like you're pretty focused on that issue.
Rally weird.
The victims of nuclear radiation are a sad thing to see.
And I have seen a lot of it.
This is such a serious topic, too.
I have seen more than enough of it.
What do you mean?
I was born and raised in Pripyat, Ukraine.
I was ten years old on that day.
April 26, 1986.
You don't mean...
Yes.
Chernobyl.
That is the day that changed my life Didn't we watch this one?
Or...
I feel like we listened to this one.
I live just three kilometers north of there.
600,000 to 700,000 people were evacuated.
Over 650,000 children suffered the effects of radiation poisoning.
Between 1986 and 1993 12,000 children died.
Oh my god.
My parents and many others like them who helped in the cleanup died a few years later.
From radiation sickness.
We must read this world of all nuclear weapons.
Before they cause more...
This is a good chance to get into the stalker series.
Before they destroy the delicate environment that keeps us alive.
I will not allow this pain and anxiety to pass on to yet another generation.
Wow, she sounded so serious there.
Mei Ling.
How's Naomi?
Huh?
It wasn't about nuclear weapons.
She's fine, I guess.
I think it's just...
nuclear technology.
What do you want, Snake?
If you want to talk to Naomi, why don't you call her?
Oh no, it's fine.
Don't worry about it.
Why is everybody calling me strange?
Good luck, Snake.
Thank you.
Alrighty.
We got all these crows.
We got...
all of this...
stuff.
Oh, giving me the C4, eh?
And the Nikita missiles.
Look at my life.
I only have two out of...
I only...
Oh, now I have three rations.
Three rations against Vulcan Raven?
With my...
Really, it's gonna feel like only two rations against Vulcan Raven.
Um...
I guess we'll see how we do next week.
Probably.
I think.
Boss fight?
We have a boss fight?
The next...
Actually...
Um...
Let's see...
We have...
Vulcan Raven...
I figured if I...
I initially was going to Endurance this.
I think if I Endurance'd it, I think I would've finished.
Because all I have is Vulcan Raven, and then...
and then...
the keys, and then...
Rex!
And the ending sequence.
So I think I would've actually been able to beat it if I had actually followed through with, um...
Endurancing it.
But I think...
Um...
Yeah, if I went for a few more hours...
Yeah, I think so.
But I think I'm gonna stop it here.
And then we'll just finish up next week.
Before I...
California!
So, I've been breaking her own spoiler rules.
Hey, hey!
I mean, lore spoilers, okay?
Not game... I've already played the Twin Snakes.
And so...
It's the same, okay?
But yeah!
Thank you always!
Here you are!
Thanks for the stream!
Thank you guys!
Yeah, actually I have some...
I have actually quite a bit of stuff I need to take care of.
Um, I have a lot of recording.
We have to record the podcast since...
Matara forgot about a collab she had this morning even though I woke up on time to...
to record.
But she completely forgot.
And so we couldn't record this morning!
Andr goes thanks for the 10 gifted!
And...
Um...
So, yeah, right after this I'm doing...
more talking.
And, uh... I have some other stuff I gotta do to prepare for next week.
And... stuff.
So...
Busy, busy, busy, busy, busy.
Thank you for the stream!
You're welcome!
And then next week...
Maybe before I go fight him...
I might go and like...
grab some rations.
Um, but I will do that off stream.
Thanks as always for MGS Brain Rock!
Good luck with Raven next week!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you guys!
I made lots and lots of progress today, so...
Um, and basically...
Almost...
Every boss...
Well, um...
Most fights in...
1, 2, 3...
Tries.
Most bosses in...
1, 2, 3 tries.
Psycho Mantis first try.
I know!
I know, right?
1 HP in a dream, baby.
Yeah.
Anyway.
3 or less!
Spank!
Thank you for the 10 gift!
Thank you!
Um, tomorrow...
Actually, I will be finishing...
Doom 64.
But also, I didn't put something on the stream.
Or on the schedule.
Of what kind of stream I will be doing.
But, I will actually be deb- Debuting...
A new chibi model that I have!
Ba-ba-da-ba!
So, um...
I just kind of got it for fun.
Because I thought it was pretty cute.
Um, so I will be debuting that tomorrow!
And, um...
Showing you guys...
That.
And maybe I'll...
Use it for streams and stuff.
So, um...
Yeah, so after the Doom 64 stream...
I'll have...
I'll have that stream as well.
Thanks for the stream!
Always a pleasure to share.
And rock with you, Minto!
Thank you!
Appreciate it.
Thank you guys so much...
For hanging out with me!
I appreciate you guys so much.
You're always, you know...
Even though it's not me playing for the first time...
And everything...
But you guys all still, you know, hang out...
And still...
Um, you know...
Still take the time to watch me.
And I'm really appreciative.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
I'm really happy that I can play this again...
And have so much fun.
So, thank you!
And, um...
There was one other thing I was gonna say...
I don't remember.
It's fine, though.
Um...
Hilbert!
Thanks for the 10 gifted!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you!
Okay, um...
Cool!
Then I'm gonna go...
Metal Gear next week will...
The continuation will actually be on Wednesday.
Because, um...
Uh...
Because I have to...
Be ready for the concert...
On Friday.
Um...
And I will still be at AX on Saturday.
I might do a stream when I get back on Sunday.
We'll see.
Not quite sure yet.
I don't remember what time I get back.
I might have gotten a red eye.
I don't quite remember.
So...
How far did you get again?
Oh, we're just about to fight Vulcan Raven.
So...
I only follow one person.
The boss.
Big boss.
You!
Me!
Oh my gosh.
I'm so excited for Delta.
I can't wait.
Yeah, we're really close to...
I'm turning these birds down.
I'm really...
I'm really close to beating this.
So I think on Wednesday we'll definitely be able to.
So sorry that it's not a Metal Gear Saturday.
But I didn't want to skip a whole week.
So...
Then...
The following weekend we'll start MGS2!
Yippee!
Yay, yay, yay!
I'm so hyped for Delta.
The more I hear about it, the more I'm hyped.
I know, right?
Yeah.
Me too, honestly.
Okie dokie!
Lalilulelo!
Ok!
Thank you guys!
I did save, right?
I did save.
Ok, I think so.
Alright!
Otzuminto!
I will see you guys...
Tomorrow?
And... yeah!
Schedule for next week.
I'm almost done making it.
I have another collab.
With a certain bird.
Actually, I asked her.
Because I've always wanted to play this game with someone.
And so I asked her if she would play it with me.
I thought it would be a fun game.
That she and I can kind of...
Be really dumb with.
So, actually...
Doki and I will be playing...
Man of Medan.
Because I thought that we could make...
Really dumb choices.
And...
To kind of troll each other.
On each...
Side, so...
But yeah...
This is MGS number 2.
It's MGS part 2!
Should I change the...
Stream title?
People are getting so confused.
But yeah...
So...
Um...
I thought that would be kind of fun.
Okie dokie!
It's clear.
IMO.
Nowhere dumb.
The title is clear.
Metal Gear Solid...
Mmm...
I never have had this issue before.
Maybe I...
I used to always put that like...
Hashtag.
Like...
Hashtag 02.
So maybe I should put...
Metal Gear Solid number 02.
But...
I thought having the part...
Just made it obvious, right?
Utano!
Thank you for membership!
Oh my gosh!
Wait!
I'm so excited for Friday!
Utano will also be at the concert with me!
You guys!
And she sings so beautifully!
So we're gonna have a lot of fun!
Oh my gosh!
I can't wait to meet you!
PT too!
Yippie yippie!
Ok.
Maybe I won't write PT too.
I'll write part 2.
I'll just write it out.
Anyways.
I've blabbered on enough.
Thank you guys!
See you guys tomorrow!
And... yeah!
Otsumito!
Bye bye!
See you guys later!